ouf salut à tous
de l'année carrément un souffle du rêve
c'est le début
il y a deux événements en un quoi si je
comprends bien
ouais je peux bon principe c'est qu'il y
a deux poules bah déjà déjà les joueurs
il y a les meilleurs joueurs du monde
qui sont représentés dans dans ce
championnat de Random de chasse ou chess
on va expliquer après les règles sauf
mais déjà on peut dire que il y a le
numéro un mondial Magnus Carlsen il sera
dans la poule B avec Hikaru Nakamura qui
dans ces cadences de rapides dans ces
positions créa devrait être ben un
joueur redoutable évidemment et on verra
le match hikao contre Magnus ce soir
donc déjà ça c'est super dans cette
poule B il y a aussi fedo CIF le joueur
russe et le jour allemand Mathias
blueboy
tous les deux joueurs à 26 50 2700 26 47
26 88 donc deux gros joueurs avec Hikaru
et Magnus poule A on a pommade et Wesley
Sow wesleaux c'est le tenant du titre
sauf et on a aussi un joueur qu'on aime
bien que tu aimes bien abdosa torov nord
du bec pourquoi parce que il avait créé
la surprise au championnat du monde
qu'on avait pu commenter stuff il y a
même pas un an et on a aussi un joueur
local alors le joueur local ça va être
quand même bien dur pour lui je sais pas
ce que tu en penses pouf mais c'est un
joueur islandais
gretharson 25-33 un grand maître on va
dire 25 33 entre 25 et 25 50 ça reste
des petits grands mètres par rapport à
l'île mondial quoi et là en face il y a
du vrai beau monde donc je pense que ça
va être un petit peu dur pour lui et
pour finir avec ta question je peux déjà
te dire ce qu'on va voir comme match
aujourd'hui
on a on a comment dirais-je donc Wesley
Sow qui joue le joueur local gretharson
dans la poule A
en match aller-retour 17h et 18h15
Abdou Sator Rohff qui sera opposé à Yann
nepomatchi donc c'est match aller-retour
à chaque fois c'est tout fin évidemment
et ampoule B on a blueba home Nakamura
en aller-retour Carl Seine fait dossehef
en aller-retour et à partir de 19 45 bah
là ça sera le deuxième match en
aller-retour avec une epomatchi contre
gretharson saut contre
et dans la poule B le gros choc entre
Nakamura et Magnus Carlsen en
aller-retour et fedecf blueborne voilà
donc franchement déjà on rentre dans le
vif du sujet ça va être super sympa
cette première journée ouais c'est clair
alors que donc le temps se passe à
Reykjavik d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a ce
joueur local à quatre personnes
donc tu sais quoi j'aime beaucoup les
les
sais pourquoi je dis ça un peu les
outsider vous savez les joueurs qui qui
sont pas pas du tout
comment dire favori mais qui finalement
crée la surprise donc je t'annonce
direct que je ne parierai pas cette
année sur Créteil
va se tirer une balle dans le pied dès
le début du stream bon je peux je peux
quand même l'aider un peu
alors par contre ce qui est clair bon on
peut parier moi ça me va très bien je
sais que quand je tous les paris 100%
par contre on peut parier sur un sur un
score qui va faire
mais pas sur une calife ni rien
score qui va faire ça sera
pas avant j'y crois pas ça va pas être
lourd
je pense que ça va être très dur
est-ce que tu as mis sur le chat il a
robinside
parce que il est 59
et j'ai toujours pas les rendre afficher
sur cheesecom je ne sais pas
comment faire
salut Fatou salut théièrement salut
charcuter salut à tous salut à tous
ouais salut à tous ceux qui arrivent
pour voir ce random de chasse alors
random chat 560 on va démarrer avec une
position aléatoire sur la première
rangée chez les Blancs sur la 8e rangée
chevet noir donc ça sera un échiquier un
petit peu bizarre oui au début de la
partie bien sûr les pions deuxième
rangée c'est les règles du jeu d'échec
que je pense que les parties sont pas
encore
lancé
parce qu'au final vous voyez là en fait
on n'a pas encore les échoquer on va
vous les mettre juste après mais parce
que comme c'est une partie qui commence
avec les pièces placer un peu au hasard
et ben les joueurs ils auraient pas le
temps de se préparer ou pas le temps de
regarder l'ordinateur ou quoi que ce
soit avant la partie vous imaginez bien
c'est pas une partie normale où on va
jouer que les pièces placées au place
initial en fait donc du coup en fait je
comprends très bien donc je me la mets
plus d'ailleurs Robinson va très très
bien
ça dépend de Bruxelles
donc du coup on va on va bientôt
commencer
toujours pas les apparents
on va attendre patiemment de toute façon
voilà on a présenté les joueurs avec un
échiquier ce sera plus simple de vous
présenter les règles
qui a déjà joué toi ou un petit peu ou
pas du tout alors très peu d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure
je t'ai demandé en off comment on fait
le petit rock
ouais ouais en fait les rocks alors moi
j'ai joué pas mal j'aurais bien pensé à
tout le monde d'aller au camping des
échecs mais il n'existe plus il y avait
un camping des échecs dans le Bordelais
stouf et on joue à plein de petits jeux
il y a des tournois carrément donc j'ai
participé à des tournois mais j'étais
assez jeune
donc c'était super sympa théorie aux
échecs ce système a été mis en place
justement pour éviter le Parker donc
voir des parties de haut niveau ou les
préparations théoriques seront
inexistantes bah ça va être assez rigolo
ouais c'est clair
moi j'aime bien ce
cette variante de jeu je trouve qu'elle
est hyper hyper bien et ça laisse des
possibilités hyper créatives aux échecs
donc ils partent créatif et puis très
tactique aussi généralement vu que
c'était on sent vraiment des sentiers
battus dès le début délai dès les
premiers coups
donc c'est vraiment être hyper
intéressant et donc dès qu'on a la
position les gars on va pouvoir en
parler un peu plus pour l'instant on
attend un petit peu
viennent d'arriver apparemment stouf
est-ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'en fait
j'ai toujours pas un gros avantage
d'avoir les blancs à
1960 du coup c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
mis en place un match aller-retour donc
vraiment il y a zéro problème quoi
ça va être l'équité va être maintenu et
évidemment comme à dire robinside
symétrie au départ sinon c'est vrai que
c'est c'est pas c'est pas drôle non
c'est pas c'est clair je vais ralentir
sont arrivés moi je les vois pas moi je
change
[Musique]
1 2 je fais tout il se passe rien donc
je vais si la position initiale elle
apparaît stouf si la vraie position des
échecs apparaît au chasse 960 il retire
il retire ouais
j'aimerais bien avoir une petite
anecdote comme ça quoi c'est quand même
pas de chance
du coup je vais retourner dans le
truc sur random
et ce qui n'est pas la bonne position
des pièces encore ok moi j'ai même pas
les deux ah ça y est j'ai kié ou ça y
est ça y est ben écoute je peux
commencer à vous montrer un peu ce qui
se passe on allait on allait partir ça
va des parties marrantes avec des fous
en c1d1
donc ça va me permettre de comment
dirais-je de parler un petit peu du
petit rock et du Grand rock on Roque sur
les cases comme au vrai échec donc
pour moi j'ai pas été vérifié les règles
si elles ont pas changé parce que je
suis un vieux joueur moi souffre comme
tu le sais
un tour des un il faut
que les cases soient disponibles
évidemment mais si j'ai mon cavalier en
comment dirais-je en H1 si Madame F1 est
partie là actuellement je pourrais faire
Roger un tour Eiffel enfin je pourrais
ok quoi tout simplement
et vous pourrez nous poser plein de
questions d'ailleurs sur ces positions
donc
on va revoir je sais pas Steven si tout
le monde a encore la position je pense
pas
tu es en train de régler tes petits
échiquiers ouais je règle
et malheureusement j'ai pas pu le faire
avant parce qu'on a eu des déchets qui
est juste à l'instant
donc
[Musique]
voilà ça arrive carène
je vois les caméras
ça va être assez rigolo de voir ça
ça va être assez rigolo de voir des
parties de très haut niveau sur le sujet
c'est surtout ça qui qui est intéressant
voir comment il joue parce qu'ils sont
bien préparés dans l'ouverture mais il y
a pas que ça
donc ça va être intéressant c'est clair
ça fait
OK
donc voilà bon pour vous dire on démarre
et 17h et ça finira à peu près vers 22h
je pense voilà on a 5 bonnes heures sur
ce sujet là et chaque soir puisqu'on se
retrouve demain après-demain il y a
aussi ce week-end les grandes finales
qui seront commentaient par blitzrim sur
sur la chaîne chasse comme ça donc cinq
jours pour vous faire au rang de chasse
ça arrive à ne vous inquiétez pas
t'inquiète pas t'inquiète pas
anglais les joueurs on a dit hein du
coup
de très très gros joueurs avec comment
dirais-je gagner pas mal chic Carlson
Nakamura et le gros choc Carlson
parce que il sait faire le teasing tout
alors je peux très fort pour ça je peux
déjà vous montrer si vous voulez le je
vous mets en grand écran
les caméras je pense que tu as comme va
laisser le rediff je vois pas trop
pourquoi je sais pas
logique je vous laisse la caméra déjà
avec 45 effets de CF là qui sont prêts à
commencer avec un petit Cavaillon H1
c'est assez drôle et pendant ce temps-là
je termine mon petit montage
de toutes les
toutes les trucs
différent tu vois moi j'aime bien
la veste de Magnus c'est plus sponsoring
et la veste de fedoceïev c'est pour
aller boire un coup ouais il est pas mal
quoi voilà
alors attends j'arrive
[Musique]
d'avoir à peu près 50 000 spectateurs là
dans la salle
genre limité dans les salles d'échec je
pense que effectivement Robinson le
disait il y a quelques mesures qui ont
été prises aussi pour que ce soit pas
n'importe quoi
non c'est clair
du monde quoi donc le spectateur tu veux
pas arriver à 35 enfin 35000 quoi
donc je pense que les joueurs qui sont
là en tant que spectateur je pense c'est
vraiment VIP quoi ça arrive vraiment à
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
vraiment
préparateur ou invités ou tu vois
de la période on va pas
c'est 25000 plus combien ah oui c'est
25000 plus un rajout de temps au bout
d'un moment c'est ça
plus 10 il me semble
en cours de partie c'est Robin side
puisque il avait l'air très fort sur le
concours de veste robinside il va nous
préciser ça
je peux vous dire que ça a commencé par
d4c5 la partie et du coup
et puis je me disais c'est bizarre qui
joue ça mais c'est vrai qu'on est en
Road home chasse donc on a on a une
Benoni pour l'instant sauf une vieille
Benny mais
j'arrive
quasiment prêt
ça va être assez assez rigolo déjà
attention les thèmes peuvent apparaître
très très vite
ça peut arriver très vite parce que du
coup on n'est pas habitué en fait c'est
position
des miniatures de temps en temps donc
là pour l'instant vous n'avez pas
l'échiquier mais bon il y a eu deux
coups de jouets on est sur la partie
de Magnus avec les pièces blanches
contre Vladimir fait d'osaiev
ah voilà regarde Robinson il a été hyper
bon 25 minutes et un incrément de 30
secondes à partir du 30e coup je crois
ok je pense qu'il a peut-être survendu
l'incrément de 30 secondes non ça fait
beaucoup ce serait pas de 10 secondes
30 secondes et à partir de 30e coup j'ai
l'impression que nous a fait un prix de
gros
pense que c'est peut-être moins allez ce
que je parie contre la banque Robinson
donc par contre j'ai qu'une seule caméra
donc et j'ai pas le long des joueurs sur
les sur les trucs
de jeu ta petite caméra qui floute
pas mal on va être pas mal
allez
du coup du coup voilà
tout nickel donc du coup qu'est-ce qui
se passe là donc il y a eu en plus c'est
vraiment une mélodie ouais c'est
vraiment une Benoni stouf c'est vraiment
ça qu'on a face à nous
et du coup c'est plutôt rigolo ouais
donc du coup ici que se passe-t-il dans
cette partie
je sais pas j'ai envie de dire que les
les blancs sont bien joué au cas tu vois
naturellement pas comme dans une vraie
je vois pas trop pourquoi
on joue autre chose est-ce que il peut y
avoir des F5 j'y crois pas du tout en
face à son roi donc E4 ça a l'air de
bien
de bien boucler la position
mais après c'est
je pense que je suis beaucoup pas mal
influencé par le fait que que c'est une
mélodie quoi
ah oui oui après en fait justement les
deux existent donc je sais pas comment
on va se mettre d'accord c'est à dire
que c'est avec mon roi en eux pour
l'instant je comprends regarde quand
même la scène me paraît un peu bizarre
sauf sur
sur le live si je vois bien je suis en
train de rechanger ça en fait là pour
être OK
[Rires]
et Robinson
ah mais c'est mon côté technique moi
j'accepte tout tu vois
mais c'est vrai que ouais
disons que tu
t'a recentrer l'échiquier sur un endroit
où il se passe pas grand chose on peut
le dire comme ça on voit un demi bout de
pion c'est voilà pourtant
donc normalement tu fais censé ok
d'accord bon en tout cas ça ça arrive ma
philosopher les gars j'ai j'ai fait un
peu nappe
et Magnus a bien joué au catch je peux
vous le dire
peut vous dire et fais de CF c'est
marrant il est en train de jouer avec sa
grosse dame
donc on coupe concours du coup sous je
suis pas mal la jouer 4 et pas ses 4 et
comme tu es dans tes réglages Obs
c'était
c'était pas facile alors que Silver CAO
c'est
ton ami une bonne et dit la réalisation
assise sur l'importance tactique des
Casa 3 à 4 et à 5
franchement c'est une énorme poubelle
j'ai l'impression dès le début pour les
noirs
j'ai l'impression que
ça me paraît bizarre de lâcher les
centres j'ai hâte que qu'on est un petit
zoom sur le centre
mais honnêtement
j'aime beaucoup ta manière de demander
les choses
est-ce que c'est plus clair ici
alors je sais pas encore ah oui voilà
c'est très très bien c'est très très
bien et vous voyez que fedoce il
respecte pas les principes et je vous
donne des 6
elles ont que Magnus il a lâche les
cases noires avec son jeu avec ses pions
blancs sans trop mais bon il a une avant
de de
oui de développement considérable
c'est-à-dire que ces pièces on voit déjà
qu'elle sorte très facilement après les
dossiers qu'il a envie d'appuyer sur la
case noire Dame des 6 fois 6
je sens pas du tout ok c'est trois et
Magnus joue hyper simple forcément là ça
sent ouais ça sent un petit peu la la
miniature j'ai envie de dire
et est-ce qu'on est-ce que on peut faire
une folie stouf et aller voir un peu les
autres échiquier pour pour se rendre
compte de la position dégradée de fait
de CF par rapport à d'autres échiquiers
un petit peu sur l'échiquier si je
comprends bien
ça te dérange pas ouais pas du tout mais
j'ai l'impression que c'est la raclette
donc j'aurais bien voulu voir comparer
comment les autres joueurs sont sont
sortis avec les noirs
disons que maintenant on joue le
développement le jeu simple au centre
c'est déjà mal parti pour pour les Noirs
ici franchement
très très mal parti
c'est même dégueu je crois que là ça va
être ça va être dur de chez dur
je te mets les parties à côté il faut
que je fasse comme ça
je suis désolé
que je vous rechange
mais t'inquiète pas j'arrive Kevin alors
là on a plus le bout de chiquer qu'on
avait tout à l'heure on a le module qui
est encore actif d'ailleurs on pourra
lever on avait la barre aussi active
mais ça va venir vous inquiétez pas
c'est petit à petit qu'on a les éléments
on va réussir à s'en sortir quand même
OK et du coup Manu si c'est pas fait
prier il a joué il a joué F4 il a pris
tout le centre et je trouve qu'il y a un
joli coup de Fed OCIF c'est fou à 5
voilà qu'il est le principe de la
Belloni en règle générale alors la
Benoni c'est une ouverture théorique on
s'appuie sur ce cadre là pour comprendre
la position et les blancs ils ont un
gros avantage au centre donc les Noirs
essaient de contrer avec le coup à 5 et
en même temps sauf j'ai pas envie de
donner mon X à 5 sur le sur le cahier C3
généralement c'est une grosse concession
quand même de case noire comme ça
d'entrée
mais bon je pense que là il est déjà en
cas en gros c'est faculté moi je pense
qu'il est quasiment foutu
prêt enfin on va pouvoir changer de
position je vais revenir sur ma fenêtre
là
le D4 C5 du départ c'était vraiment
c'est vraiment atroce quoi
tu aimes bien avoir la balle à la barre
puis d'ailleurs on m'avait demandé de
laisser la barre sur fiascam
ça il faut la laisser par contre nous je
nous ai enlevé le
variantes les variantes pour qu'on
puisse rêver chaque notre tête je pense
que c'est plus sympa mieux pour les gens
ils sont plus contents je pense de de
voir des coups humains plutôt que tout
simplement regarder les coût de
l'ordinateur quoi
autant tous les coups de la partie était
à peu près logique le centre mais là je
comprends pas
il peut jouer le rock mais bon alors
pour expliquer aux gens un peu l'Europe
comment on fait pour roquer en fait en
ses positions c'est simple
si les cases de rock c'est à dire le roi
ici la tour ici sont libres il y a pas
de pièces au milieu et bien sûr je suis
pas en échec etc et ben on peut faire le
rock donc pour le rock et ben
on fait ça donc le roi sera en G1 la
tour sera en F1 si mon roi était en B1
par exemple là je pourrai pas ok parce
qu'il y a encore deux fois au milieu et
c'est par exemple bien je sors mes deux
fous là je peux reculer avec la tour
géant
et du coup le roi est engin la torrir en
F sera le rock normal c'est bien c'est
un camion
du rock classique effectivement sauf
donc là je pense que son idée c'est
peut-être de te faire petit rock et de
commencer à lui attaquer le le roi noir
il faut voir aussi que les noirs peuvent
aussi croquer de leur côté
donc c'est
intéressant de voir qu'au final le roi
noir il est pas forcément
emprise pour l'instant donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe quand même sur un coup
comme comme dessin pour voir
parce que je suis cloué quand même je te
rappelle
ouais
cavalier F5 enfin franchement j'ai
l'impression que l'avantage de
développement et des tal qui pouvait se
permettre pas mal de choses mais bon il
a pas voulu pas osé plus fort quel G3 E5
aussi sur epran D ça ça avait l'air
détonnant mais là eux prend des prend
des toujours je pense tout 5 peut-être
de prendre 5 la dame moi pas trop de
case je peux encore là aussi peut-être
le coup numéro 1 parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y a plus on prend il y a dedans je
pense
après
tout existe
encore
des roquets donner la paire de fou ben
c'est quand même pas simple j'ai F5 F6
qui peut arriver très vite
aussi elle a pas mal quand même parce
qu'il y a quand même du F5 qui va
arriver
franchement je donne pas cher de la peau
de
fedo dans celle-là
bon après les Noirs ça peut être très
dur donc bon juste une mauvaise position
de le départ quoi
est-ce que tu veux qu'on aille voir du
coup notre partie
[Musique]
parce que maintenant
tout simplement je menace de mange en
dessin
et puis aussi j'ai les menaces E5 F5 en
fait je garde toutes les menaces si vous
voulez découvrir le centre ici ou de
prise en
dessin du cavalier Bessin qui peut
arriver en fait juste je te dis ok moi
je vois que derrière toi quoi
c'est facilement
donc j'imagine peut-être 5
sur T4 j'ai pas encore les couleurs
salut Guillaume
on a un délai de 5 minutes je crois ah
oui oui d'accord est-ce que la caméra il
y a un délai je pense pas non ça doit
être je pense que la caméra est chic et
son même niveau de délai parce que sinon
[Musique]
on est bien posé on est très très bien
posé et on peut aller voir une autre
partie pour voir juste le début pour
comparer un peu stouf les différents
débuts
contre Nakamura dans le même groupe du
coup
blueba avec les Blancs contre moi
et donc
ce que l'ouverture a été plus conforme
donc l'ouverture on peut regarder alors
E4 donc c'est la même position ils ont
tous la même position
[Musique]
une tour comme ça avec une tour en B1 et
de prendre à deux
trucs là quand même 4 on sort les pièces
il sort le cavalier et juste solide
blue boom
donc là j'imagine peut-être un
Cameron qui commence à regarder à ce que
je joue le 5 bah oui c'est ça le
problème c'est que je pense qu'il veut
maîtriser cette poussée là avec les
blancs mais elle a pas encore
pas évident
pour les deux parce que bien sûr
un coup avec les Noirs maintenant voilà
c'est joué en direct live et
rock ouais mais attention que le rock
c'est chaud quand même aussi hein parce
qu'il y a un visage aussi et par exemple
une idée qui pourrait avoir un jour bon
pour l'instant peut-être pas et par
exemple comme cavalier 4 pour venir sur
les cadres G5 ou quoi il y a un clouage
en fait il y a le roi et la dame en fait
on peut se servir des fois tu me
tactique pour ramener des pièces en jeu
mais moi j'aime bien les Noirs perso
déjà comment dirais-je à peu près réussi
son son ouverture placement des pièces
blanches et un peu plus bizarres et
comme le fait remarqué Fatou modo sur le
chat c'est beau de les voir réfléchir
sur l'ouverture et c'est clair qu'à ce
niveau là normalement ils connaissent
les ils connaissent la théorie jusqu'à
très très loin et tu les vois jamais
vraiment
planter au cinquième coup quoi tu vois
c'est ça en plus c'est une des achats
qui doivent pas beaucoup travailler ils
se là il s'amusent les mecs ils sont
vraiment bon ça reste quand même
champion du monde donc ils veulent tous
gagner tu vois surtout Magnus peut-être
je pense qu'ils veulent gagner ouais je
pense que le favoris quoi parce que
bluebom on te dit là pour gagner aussi
mais
lui il est plus là pour l'instant je
pense
mais c'est vrai que quand tu vois
Carlson
népaume tout cela ils veulent gagner
quoi ça c'est clair je pense que
qatarsson
d'ailleurs on va pouvoir donc là bon
position un peu plus normale mais c'est
vrai qu'on peut faire un petit tour des
échiquiers là pour voir un peu les
ouvertures quoi alors on va les voir
l'eau
ou la la c'est déjà avec le roi en 17 on
va aller voir ce qui s'est passé parce
que lui il a pas manqué alors peut-être
que nepo il ne sait pas ok on va lui
expliquer alors donc je rappelle quand
même que apps c'est champion du monde de
partir rapide actuellement
il n'a que 18 ans et il a gagné le
championnat du monde de partir rapide en
départage contre une épaule justement
c'est qu'on a tous une seule en fait
d'accord
alors il y avait plusieurs systèmes de
qualification il prenait le vainqueur de
du dernier chocolat du monde de randoms
donc Wesley Sow le finaliste car la
scène il prenait un invité feed un
invité local et quatre qualifiés par
internet sur les
sites.com voilà comment ça s'est passé
et
alors le plateau donc là là c'est
absolument avec les Blancs contre un
épaumenerachi malheureusement je n'ai
pas
[Musique]
je n'ai pas plus
pour changer ça mais du coup ça va me
faire
en fait leur truc était tellement petit
que tu peux si je le mets
je vous le mets mais bon
là tu donnes une pause des questions
comme ça c'est très très bien ça fait du
travail pour je trouve qu'il gère la
technique moi je peux rien faire vous
savez que si ça a été moi la technique
mais c'était l'assurance totale d'avoir
vraiment des siennes parfaites et en
plus avec beaucoup de réactivité mais là
c'est stouf qui gère la technique
aujourd'hui
voilà donc bon on est indulgent mais
indulgent ne veut pas dire pas exigeant
stouf donc voilà
j'avais les cadres donc là je dépasse un
peu du cadre je pourrais faire
différemment mais c'est tout petit donc
c'est pas très magnifique c'est
magnifique ce que tu nous as fait je
sors un peu du cadre j'espère
franchement honnêtement on voit pas et
c'est nickel assez nickel moi j'adore et
d'ailleurs l'ordre aussi
pour votre soutien
juste pour dire niveau sens plus deux
fois moins fort que Kevin c'est parce
que je crie je pense non mais
en cours en cours de réglage
mais pas tout vous voulez pas rajouter
un problème technique
je comprends mieux
j'ai un peu baissé le tien vous me dites
on va voir comment les pots a mis son
roi ouais pourtant
très vite
mais c'était plutôt pour bloquer le
centre visiblement
il y a F3 E4 qui peut être peut-être
l'explication pour pour tout exploser
qu'on n'a pas de cavalier en F3 donc
c'est une petite différence donc là
c'est quand même une position presque
presque normale de avec le cavalier qui
devait être là ou là ou des fois le
cavaliers
change tout en fait ici c'est ça qui est
rigolo
par rapport à mon expérience
vous savez généralement on ne bouge pas
des fois la même pièce dans l'ouverture
ça vous le savez donc quel âge 4 c'est
un coup qui me fait un peu
[Musique]
halluciné en vrai
4 et on a intérêt de faire gaffe
il veut balancer il veut tout balance
moi je pense que vraiment une peau
c'est clairement le type de mec qui veut
vraiment
s'amuser quoi je pense que lui il aime
bien ses positions tu vois c'est des
cadences différentes on va dire variante
du déchets différents et tout simplement
un époux il faut s'amuser là qu'il y a
H4 tu vois c'est
franchement
de voir toutes les pièces arrivées
donc lui il attaque mais en fait
super bien joué
on peut le faire aussi en partie alors
bon normalement s'il y a de la théorie
ok c'est plus difficile mais pour les
jours amateurs c'est quand même très
pédagogique que ça vient de faire
avec comment on dirait-je une ouverture
du centre parce que le roi ennemi est
sur la colonne quoi
donc
on dit souvent
affaiblissement à l'aile réaction au
centre et du coup nepo cavalier H4 j'ai
5 bah tu as clairement envie de
l'attaquer au centre avec son roi qui
sont passés donc F3 rock prise M4 c'est
juste complètement normal et tu as
l'impression qu'ici c'est la pls qui
arrive là donc là
salut à toi pourquoi il y a pas Emmy
human merci pour la question
j'ai l'habitude t'inquiète pas et
pourtant je suis remonté en vélo je suis
remonté
[Musique]
là j'ai perdu une partie de ma maman qui
m'a fait pas beaucoup de points
mais j'étais à 83 là ah oui
je suis remonté mais là j'ai fait une
partie où j'ai perdu un jour très faible
et 17
c'est vrai
donc c'est super et donc ouais ouais bon
bah ça arrive
[Musique]
plus bon en fait non c'est pas vraiment
vrai parce que c'est une position
compliquée quand même mais
en fait tout le temps
[Musique]
et
j'ai complètement blender que sur mon
roi dans sa parole en fait genre
c'est que il m'a fait donc dame prend
dame obligatoire et à pion prend dames
quoi enfin juste en deux coups quoi tu
vois en gros obligatoire et il fait dame
derrière et je peux pas m'empêcher donc
complètement tu rêves 23 70 quelque
chose comme ça 66 67 oui non c'est clair
tu as 24 heures et quelques mois donc je
m'en rappelle justement
mais donc ça va tu vois j'ai pas je suis
quand même content d'avoir monté mais
bon il y a encore beaucoup de choses à
faire quoi
donc revenons à quand même l'événement
d'aujourd'hui c'est pas tout fait ou pas
là c'est
donc sur un dessin il a 5 et la pièce
tu vois qu'il a il a donné le Cavalaire
je crois ouvrir la position mais contre
deux pions éventuellement en cas de prix
G3 repris G3 réattaque le cavalier H4
plus le roi donc c'est à pion en fait en
réalité ouais donc en fait c'est réussi
du matériel mais pour ouvrir le roi
adverse du coup c'est assez intéressant
vous voyez les pièces noires sont pas du
tout développées
et donc tout Rouen roi des 7 du coup
alors sur Full 7 il y aurait eu des six
qui
clouer le fouet donc
roi D7 prise et je prends ceci et en
finale ben on a l'impression quand même
que que le roi noir il va se prendre
va se prendre une grosse attaque là il y
a tous les fous qui arrivent il y a la
dame qui arrive aussi en B5 il y a prise
ici
ça a l'air quand même hyper fort pour se
faire
comme il va faire pour tenir la position
ça a l'air juste un vol en fait
complètement
après à ce niveau là de défendre des
pollutions indéfendables donc on va voir
mais bon c'est pas un client quoi je
pense franchement
position comme ça avec attaque de maths
il devrait être capable de venir finir
la partie elle a l'air facile à jouer la
position des blancs vis-à-vis
j'ai du cavalier C5 sur échange de
pièces je mange du pion je m'imagine on
va garder le vis-à-vis
et
un cauchemar cavalier prend cavaler
prend ok donc là on peut imaginer
et fouette c'est la partie mais
en plus on voit la courbe on voit le la
part des déviation je vous rappelle que
nous on commente sans l'ordinateur on a
on va pas les commentaires on va pas se
mettre dans l'ordinateur on va pas
évaluation donc juste sur Roissy 7 on
pensait à vous à 5 sur cavali B6 du coup
le café devrait plus le foot le foot
donc juste après le cavalier B6 on
pourrait capturer le fou et sur eyes et
du coup sur Roy ici foulard si le roi
part sur la 8ème rangée et ben la tour
serait plus défendue par l'autre tour
parce que le roi serait devant donc au
projet la tour donc en fait je pense
là c'est impossible et si le roi va ici
on mange la tour
donc là juste c'est un endroit
c'est bizarre d'avoir 13 minutes pour
dépôt une partie
petite partie pour démarrer son tour
parce que franchement c'est clair
franchement on fait une petite partie en
3-0 en random chasse on n'est pas très
satisfait de faire ça déjà
et puis on G5 direct vous voyez même les
meilleurs pros du monde peut faire des
erreurs enfin l'ouverture en fait elle a
été vraiment on peut le dire je pense
hein catastrophique pour pour dépôt
qui voulait quelque chose de bien solide
je pense pour pas se faire défoncer et
c'est pris F3 E4 et son mur de pierre a
complètement implosé ouais bah après
s'il avait joué différemment que ça et
ça tu vois tu aurais pu
voir venir le truc quoi tu vois c'est à
dire que là il a un problème de
développement avec les noirs bien sûr tu
pars pas sur le côté à balancer G5 enfin
c'est juste
c'est juste bizarre quoi tu vois mais on
a insisté sur les parties
de Carlsen dans les deux cas on voit que
les noirs ont des chances de perdre
quasiment tout de suite quoi donc faut
faire vraiment gaffe parce qu'on se
prend vraiment une pression de folie les
joueurs avec les blancs vont vouloir
prendre très très rapidement
l'initiative et ça peut déconner mais la
partie de très très pédagogique
comme quoi les gars sentaient bien vos
pièces
ne bougez pas deux fois la pièce dans
l'ouverture tout ça cavaillage 4 c'est
très mal joué le jeu avec les pions
cette petite manœuvre F3 E4 c'est
justement ce qui manque des fois au
joueur amateur je dirais sauf tu sais la
les ruptures avec les pions qui
permettent d'ouvrir les lignes bah là en
l'occurrence sur le roi quand vous voyez
que vous avez l'entente de développement
ici il faut essayer de vite ouvrir la
position et donc F3
systématique
gain blanc abdosa torov terminado
à gagner après 5 x 5
il a sacrifié la pièce pour ouvrir la
position
[Musique]
donc
grosse partie donc je vous rappelle que
les deux premiers de chaque groupe se
qualifieront pour les demi-finales et
qu'avec cette défaite népot il est il
est candidat à sortir
c'est à dire que maintenant on devra
gagner absolument contre saut et contre
Greta sol et voir ce qui se passe quoi
d'ailleurs on va aller voir un peu ce
qui se passe chez
tout à l'heure c'est le numéro 1
islandais après comme ça allait retour
il peut encore se refaire quoi
il a encore ça merci il a aussi la
partie retour donc pour se revoir
donc alors tu vois tu peux pas dire
beaucoup de choses à côté ouais je peux
pas faire n'importe quoi
donc du coup crétinson qui lui est le
numéro 1 irlandais et islandais du coup
islandais
je préfère te le dire sinon c'est
Robinson 5 qui va de le dire et je pense
que c'est pire je connais pas trop les
drapeaux tu vois pour moi je veux dire
ok
du coup du coup bon numéro 1 islandais
donc à seulement entre guillemets en
2500 333 Hello
et au final donc on va voir un peu ce
qu'il fait dans ce temps là parce que
c'est quand même un tournoi qui est qui
est
ultra
ultra fort
donc c'est
la différence de niveau pour moi devrait
parler parce que la créativité des des
joueurs de très haut niveau comme moi
c'était so et autres de devrait lui
faire mal en tout cas c'est ce que
j'estime d'assaut il est juste hyper
fort en fait
du roi ouais c'est ça
il y a toujours des ruptures rapides en
fait
[Musique]
et ça va un peu penser de ça au parti de
l'époque tu vois avec bien sûr très
romantique sans théorie
avec les tous les Gambiers Gréco toutes
ces trucs là et en fait du coup il y a
pas de théorie donc on va juste tu joues
agressif et tu prends l'initiative et tu
as on fait peur sauf ouais c'est ça
donc il y a eu des trois
c'est 6 ok dare F2 donc ça a l'air ouais
mais en fait encore une fois ok
attention à pas se prendre le petit
clouage là ok il a vu faux 3 donc il y a
pas trop inquiet
et les blancs moi j'aime bien les blancs
ici ils ont plus ils ont bougé plusieurs
fois la dame mais au final une fois que
je peux tiens tu peux être pas mal il a
bien travaillé avec une cible en F7 donc
des cinq c'est la c'est la c'est la
rupture thématique et là j'aime beaucoup
ce coup parce que on prend
je pense qu'on va avoir l'hôpital B4 qui
va arriver c'est ça c'est vrai qu'ils
ont joué C3 les blancs du coup dans
cette position et c'est vrai que dans B4
c'était vicieux double menace tactique
stratégique parce que si tu manges juste
en descente ta position elle est pas
bonne tu as un pion isolé ici qui est
pas forcément très bien tu vois on va
essayer vite ok mettre tes cavaliers
enfin sortir les pièces etc mais c'est
vrai ici
si on prend et ben il va y avoir de MP4
échec je pense que c'est l'idée
clairement pour aller manger B2 et à la
tourisme
du random de chasse on si on a une
baisse d'attention on peut se faire
directement enfoncer
du coup C3 donc t'empêche d'un Mb4 et
après la prise en 4 il a mangé un cadre
maintenant du coup ce qui est blanc qui
ont un pion qui ont un pion isolé en E4
donc dame C5 attaque la tour qui empêche
aussi franchement propre
il faut aussi
ok donc
pour l'instant il n'y a pas dit ou une
allure
il change les pièces cavaler prend dame
5 ok donc c'est final ça souffrir
maintenant c'est final sont toujours
mieux pour les Noirs
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr en fait je pense qu'au
pire des cas je vais faire d'un B6
qui avait c'était hyper chaud dans les
deux sens
même perdu
mais au pire d'un B6 en fait et juste en
fait la pollution elle est mauvaise pour
les blancs s'il y a plus d'armes en fait
parce que tu as un pion isolant E4 et
que moi je contrôle bien la case donc je
mets un Cavaillon E5
je vais bien bloquer la case de 5 et sur
le long terme en fait et ben l'option 4
va être faible et en plus le foodien
c'est le mauvais fou de la pollution des
blancs donc voilà
sur le long terme les blancs ne sont pas
bien en plus dans la partie
saut qui est quand même largement favori
dans cette partie et ben
saut est su qu'elle est noir ce qui va
pousser donc ça m'a l'air d'être
position difficile pour pour les blancs
tout ça psychologique ou même juste
pratique quoi j'ai vu la cam de Magnus
aussi alors d'avoir une grosse attaque
ça a l'air après on passe rapidement
ici là qu'est-ce qu'elle va les prendre
le 5 donc un échange grand rock recettes
donc on est en finale c'est logique de
faire roi E7 ça c'est une belle potion
de fille d'or tu vois je rêverais
d'avoir cette position
grand spécialiste de la flore
ont fait un gros score en ce match là
des fois ça marche bientôt
[Musique]
on va remettre ça lors de nos trois
jours là de commentaire je suis sûr que
ça nous permet
il faut que je prenne ma revanche
alors c'est ça que c'est quand même un
coup c'est responsable parce que tu
donnes des gaz quand même tu donnes des
cases
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à
expliquer pourquoi il a juste là
la soliday ça peut être C4 cavaliers des
trois termes ouais mais tu as le temps
de le faire
il fait il estime faire une petite
concession et
l'autre une énorme concession
mais c'est bizarre quand même je sais
pas je sais pas de quoi à quoi te dire
c'est ça que ça m'a l'air d'être un coup
antipollutionnel qui donne beaucoup de
cases à l'adversaire
après si on a peut-être C4 cavaliers C5
il s'est dit
oui d'ailleurs il a fait tour C8 je
crois on laisse les sauts derrière et du
coup
il va peut-être préparer ça mais
attention
c'est la problématique la tour des cinq
elle est pénible
ça c'est clair
la tour et le pion incapable qui est
quand même dur à défendre
de la part des blancs d'aller vers F4 D5
cavalier H3 c'est un très un coup très
esthétique
cavalier au bord cavalier fort là pour
le coup en fait vous voyez il est GT5
donc du coup il donne des cases pour
l'adversaire donc on va essayer de se
diriger vers la case des 5 ça arrive par
logique ok donc du coup parti qui qui
qui est pas si clair franchement je mets
beaucoup les Noirs jusqu'à 5 c'est 5
bien sûr j'aime pas
j'aime pas
[Musique]
très normal ce qui s'est passé bon alors
bizarre
[Musique]
peut-être qu'on aura des
alarmes
on s'est arrêté à E5
dans le 7 et le cavalier qui vient sur
la case F5
avec encore une fois l'initiative c'est
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'important d'échec il y a quelqu'un qui
va être un jour possible une fois qu'on
sera déroqué enfin qu'on aura un roquet
pardon
ça donne bien envie et je vous foutais 7
qui a l'air d'être
bof bof et si je rock ah oui il y a
toujours
[Musique]
j'y crois pas trop
il y a peut-être une blague de
retransmission
[Rires]
mais la suite peut-être qu'il joue au 3
échec je sais pas
après je joue au 3 échec en robe ça peut
être marrant aussi hein ouais mais là
ouais
non mais en fait grosse gros problème de
retranscription sur la partie
malheureusement on n'a pas vu la cam et
en plus bah la partie était hyper dans
la partie il y a eu un projet si je l'ai
vu à la cam tout à l'heure et ça valait
hyper chaud
il y a des problèmes clairement de
retransmission
donc
malheureusement on peut pas on peut pas
vous
pas vous peut-être plus tard on aura la
potion qui va un peu soldater je vais
voir si je peux
est-ce que si je fais ça
ah tiens la partie qui a qui a super je
vais vouloir montrer du coup le prendre
la technique t'ouvre bravo
on a problématique n'aurait pas pensé
4 E5 ok ça a plus de sens dans le 7
cavalier E4 donc là
on est quasiment foutu
3 cavaliers
il a plus de choix
dans le
ton F3 menace le petit
dame j'ai regardé un petit joli d'un
projet 6 prise et tout ça
mais le problème c'est qu'il peut pas
faire grand-chose en fait positions
[Musique]
on peut montrer tout reprendre un
chiffre ouais ah non pas du tout
j'ai vu un truc jusqu'au bout mais dans
ma tête
à la place si tu montes dans ma chatte
ça marche OK
et je dis à mes élèves sauf toujours de
pas calculer à fond une branche et de
laisser une autre branche complètement à
l'abandon c'est exactement ce que je
viens de faire c'est pour réveiller tout
le monde un petit peu
[Musique]
[Rires]
ok ben
grosses masterclass pour la part de
Carlson dans cette partie en même temps
on vient de voir 2-01 2-0 dans des
matchs bon pas assez serré mais fait
d'océf c'est un très bon joueur aussi
mais ça a été deux parties à sens unique
où les Blancs ont quasiment dominé et
dans les autres parties c'est les
outsiders qui ont les blancs
et Greta Arson contre Wesley Sow donc ça
s'explique quand même alors d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui se passe chez Bloom Naka
il y a pas mal de trucs qui
qui sont qui se passent là alors on va
revenir un petit peu à la pollution
qu'on avait on s'est arrêté à à E5 de la
part de Naka qui avait l'air assez
ambitieux hyper intéressant donc E5 d'un
B5 du coup attaque le pion dessin
un peu si il se laisse les deux rocks à
disposition
donc elle va laisser le 7 tranquillement
il défend il va peut-être faire cesser
un jour seul position quand même de ce
qu'on a vu ce tofu vraiment les Noirs
prennent l'initiative incroyable quoi
dans le début les autres très forts ont
réussi à faire mal il y a que d'ailleurs
gretharson qui s'est fait bloquer par
Wesley Sow donc on voit qu'ils
n'arrivent pas quand même comme les
autres à prendre l'initiative débordante
là il s'est fait un peu un peu rouler je
trouve
majorité centrale des belles pièces
alors juste E4 qui avait l'air
intéressant pour prendre le centre je me
ferais un petit peu aux gens
c'est pas du tout un bon coup ici hein
parce que du coup il y a un gros
vis-à-vis de la part de l'endroit et la
dame il y aurait ici cavaliers
de voir ce qui se passe dans cet endroit
qui joue un peu tempo tous les deux
sur Internet et en live aussi
il va mettre la pression au temps
il joue vite
donc c'est peut-être ça qui veut avec
les blancs
en plus
d'un
accélère un petit peu
quand même pression des Noirs quand même
avec les fous qui pourront venir bon un
jour et la majorité qui pourra aussi
avancer peut-être le KFC la majorité
centrales qui est forte tu as raison on
souffle plus agréable pour les noirs
sont pas bien organisées même mon four
en D4 le jour où il avancerait
en position difficile à
à jouer pour alors du coup sauf si je
vois bien les pendules ils ont eu un
petit bonus de 5 minutes pour être
entièrement
ah oui
ils viennent d'arriver au 30e en bas
ouais
et oui il a pas peur qui va manger le
temps
c'est un pion ça c'est clairement dans
son style
il y aura une découverte sur
sur le cavalier
phases critiques qui met la pression sur
ses adversaires c'est terrible les
raisons il a mangé le pion il repart et
maintenant il se dit qu'il a un pion de
plus quoi la position elle est tout à
fait normale quoi et franchement il a
raison hein
et là peut-être que pour essayer de
faire c'est fou F5 changer les fous
et moi aussi
je pense que tu en penses
trouver quelque chose pour les blancs de
concret
de ramener un petit peu
les pièces noires le foot quasiment pour
l'instant il est en C7 il est un petit
peu hors jeu c'est un C4 ah j'aime bien
ces quatre
ouvrir les cases blanches avec son fou
B3
hyper intéressant comme comme
des joueurs amateurs nous-mêmes ça
serait bien de d'y penser mais c'est
vrai que la rupture c'est hyper bien
joué et en plus sur le long terme il est
mal avec avec les Blancs parce qu'il y a
un pion de moins il est jaloux du centre
noir et il profite de la désorganisation
soudaine des pièces noires pour ouvrir
le centre c'est super bien joué
à ce coup
parce que moi ça me saoulerait bien
quelque chose sur la diago qui commence
à s'affaiblir la diago que tu as montré
la diagoa de G8 je pense aussi à Tours
on a envie de mettre tous les deux en
tout cas le foin
mauvais en vrai mettre en dessin en fait
simplement contre un peu des cases la
grande diagonale blanche qui est hyper
faible
mettre le fou ici en Dassin ce serait
une bonne nouvelle ce serait un organisé
après pour ramener mon fou quelque part
là si je pouvais être mon four en dessin
qui me font en G7 le roi du monde
mais malheureusement c'est pas si simple
que ça
salut Pat
ate
[Musique]
c'est chaud alors
alors qu'est-ce que tu bois tout on a
envie de savoir un petit une petite
orangeade ou un petit cocktail de par
chez toi
c'est un petit Fanta Fanta
des Canaries
dans ton choix de boisson mais bon
[ __ ] d'ailleurs j'ai oublié attends
j'arrive je t'explique après je suis
désolé j'arrive
bon en tout cas franchement retenez ce
coup C4 c'est vraiment
et vous voyez en plus les joueurs ont
quand même pas beaucoup de temps
5 minutes chacun grosso modo un peu
moins maintenant Naka avait 6 minutes au
début quand on se proue et survenu mais
c'est pas facile de réagir pour lui les
blancs trouvent de l'initiative et
modifie la structure d'option ce qui est
une réaction dynamique modification de
position le jeu dynamique c'est
l'évolution des structures les échanges
aussi qui peuvent changer une position
qu'est-ce que tu es parti faire tu avais
oublié un plat dans le four
une boisson justement dans le congélo
que je suis arrivé un petit peu à la
rage tout à l'heure j'avais fait
quelques courses et
qu'est-ce que tu as pu mettre au congélo
quand il fait très chaud je dirais des
bières pour le stream c'est parfait les
bières
[Rires]
de Fanta qui est ici
une seule en fait au congelo pour être
enfin et puis je l'ai oublié et du coup
là elle est très très fraîche c'est cool
j'aime bien quand c'est frais mais par
contre elle explose quand même
il y a le stream mais il y a la presse
stream il est quelle heure chez toi là
sauf une heure de moins que toi ouais
17h donc le stream il se finit juste
bien en fait parfait pour l'apéro ouais
voilà c'est ça
pouvait porter à confusion à tourner
cette foule F7 donc voilà
il a trouvé la bonne défense alors fou
bet3 pardon ça va sûrement être le coup
je peux pas te laisser
mettre ton four en dessin gratuitement
mais comment est-ce que je termine
il a l'air content de demain vous voyez
la caméra bluebom c'est lui il est pas
content il a atteint un truc il sent que
qu'il a
qu'il a raté quelque chose
donc je pense que
ouais non ça a l'air d'aller mais je
pense que il a il a raté quelque chose
en tout cas il est pas content ouais des
fois on peut s'énerver sauf on connais
ça d'avoir raté un coup d'avoir cru
quelque chose ne sera jamais quoi mais
satisfaisant pourtant cette position
j'avais une idée rigolote souffle qui
marchait peut-être pas du tout je te
propose juste vite fait sauf
[Musique]
j'avais envie de jouer dams 3 et
peut-être il faut prendre G6 ou tour H1
il faut prendre G6
bricoler un truc comme ça ouais
t'as peut-être tout rachète je vais
passer la tour en
H16 la thématique qu'en fait que je
voulais c'est de passer mais ça marche
pas
plusieurs coups peut-être même
roi de ta cache non mais bon j'ai des
coups comme toi
de toute façon je veux jouer dynamique
parce que sinon je vais être foutu donc
du coup avec idée que j'entends prendre
des dessins qui étaient absolument
[Musique]
parce que on doit s'activer sur les
échanges avec avec les noirs on doit
casser l'initiative
et j'aime bien ce qui fait quand même
mine de rien Bloom parce que il garde la
pression quand même sur les cases noires
sur la paire de fou qui va vraiment bien
viser le roi éventuellement un jour un
fousset 3 pour l'espace la dame sur la
case noire
non franchement j'aime bien ce qu'il
fait avec le noir tu vois en pratique
c'est ça a l'air très très dur à jeu
pour pour un petit coup malin
c'était pas un petit coup malin
des fougères
[Musique]
de fou prendre à deux échec dans la
position que j'essaie de faire marcher
sauf mais il faut faire le bon coin
gratuits
genre tous deux et un jour F4 le fou il
peut il peut être perdu
alors
il fait la gueule
[Musique]
en fait ce que je voulais faire tout à
l'heure
sinon c'est des super fort mais il y a
peut-être un coup de tour tout à chaque
H5
[Musique]
j'en ai pas parlé non je veux pas mais
là peut-être je sais pas fous c'est 4 ou
tout rachat quelque chose comme ça
qui trouve les défenses quand même
la gueule de l'attaque blanche et du
coup c'est terminato maintenant
dangereuse ça va retenir quand même
il a gardé la pression au temps et il a
cassé il a fait l'antijeu global il va
il va imploser maintenant dans cette
position vraisemblablement
on n'est pas cher que ça pour un et tout
et 3 avec Dame D6 donc il fait passer le
fou là en premier la dame qui défend qui
permet de jouer au sein derrière quoi je
trouve que c'est une raison de souligner
ça parce que c'est une défense très
active c'est de la contre-attaque sauf
moi j'ai remarqué que nombre de joueurs
amateurs moi-même c'est pareil
d'ailleurs dans certaines positions je
suis sous pression autant sous pression
en position je me délite un petit peu je
commence à faire quelques coups par
l'arrière tu vois et du coup bah là
c'est tout l'inverse d'accord il
continue après c'est à faire mal à
chaque coup
[Musique]
j'ai rien à craindre je pense que c'est
ça va être
c'est devenu beaucoup plus facile
est-ce que tu veux qu'on aille voir un
peu ce qui se passe c'est mieux il y a
donc une pression maintenant donc on
avait notamment
qui a pas encore fini
alors
je vais revenir au s’arrêter à truc
il aura pas valorisé avec les
cinq qui a permis la rentrée des pièces
il a dû se tromper sur quelque chose ou
est-ce les sauts qui est si doué il a
joué un courant anti-pollutionnel en
connaissance de cause donc il avait sans
doute vu quelque chose mais ça n'a pas
abouti en tout cas
donc là du coup il a joué
au final
cette bonne file d'or qui a donc il a
laissé la photo parce que si il mange la
tour eh ben il y a plus on prend avec
découverte sur sur la tour de cercle
donc avaler là et la grosse case en
dessin maintenant pour les blancs tour
des deux ça tricote Caval qui arrive
finalement en dessin il échange mais
c'est qu'il a un autre Caval qui peut
arriver encore en dessin aussi la
colonne ouverte par exemple après
cavalier 5 je pense que le jugement je
joue en V3 et
il y a une grosse pression des blancs
sur la colonne
pour des systèmes
on ramène le roi et bonne position je
pense pour les blancs qui va sûrement se
terminer en une mais c'est plutôt une
bonne performance pour il a fait une
jolie partie pour démarrer gretharson
[Musique]
avec l'histoire du pion B3 qui pourrait
être perdu
du coup il a fait des six si tu prends
là
chaque prise qui veut forcer un peu les
choses
il faudrait simplifier la position
plutôt comme ça
plutôt que d'aller partir en G8 quand
même
mais c'est vrai qu'un dangereux celle-là
je pensais aussi un autre thème c'était
cavalier E5 voix F6 peut-être mais je
sais pas si ça marchait
ouais ok
juste pour faire gaffe au cavaliers
plutôt mal placé le roi fist accueille
G8 peut-être
non
j'ai pas le temps de faire G4
d'abord dans tous les rois F4 les pièces
sont bizarres mais bon ça a l'air de
ressortir quand même
qui est intéressant à envoyer niveau il
veut pas manger le pion sur échec
un peu dangereux quand même ce qu'il a
joué avec
complètement trompé en fait
justement où on sentait toujours pareil
que Greta Arson il allait faire une
bonne première partie il allait faire
nul mais en fait c'est complètement
bourré
[Musique]
comme ça au final juste saut c'est le
mec qui va pas te pardonner quoi tu vois
au moment où on dit ça
donc
après la ça a l'air perdu en Europe qui
avance
que ça semblait bon ok c'était beaucoup
mieux et oui on avance le roi
tranquillement hop voilà il a tenu le
pion avec le cavalier
[Musique]
quoi
alors on va le vendre c'est la seule
partie qui reste
mais bon il est il est complètement
gagnant quand même non avec l'option C2
il a quand même deux fois pour la
qualité et un pion une case la dame pour
faire attention c'est compliqué c'est
assez compliqué cette position là il
reste 10 secondes chacun
à la vidéo alors je vais voir si j'ai
une caméra qui est un peu mieux que ça
peut-être pour vous montrer alors
peut-être jamais je sais pas je vais
voir aïe aïe aïe on voit la gaffe en
direct de de Blue bam est-ce que je peux
faire c'est un Dam et voilà et dame F7
malheureusement Rohff c'est il y a plus
de il y a plus assez d'échecs
je vous ai mis les je vous ai mis la
caméra il a pas il a pas vu
tu as vu c'est terrible il s'est trompé
il a raté la phase technique visiblement
et carreaux en fait quand il avait tu
sais la qualité en plus le roi de
bluebaam dénudé et il avait l'air
complètement gagnant et il s'est trompé
il s'est
non mais c'est chaud en fait c'est
polissons si tu veux sur casse blanche
ça va tenir à chaque fois
et
il faut trouver trois millions
tu prends je fais dames c'est un peu
comme tout à l'heure en pleinement 4 et
5 je vais changer les dames donc si tu
prends la dame bah juste
cette pollution est-ce qu'elle est si
simple à gagner
elle avait l'air mais si le roi arrivant
des deux
mais je peux pas vraiment
[Musique]
ça l'ordinateur à
et ouais c'est ça n'a pas gagné il est
en train de jouer donc on va aller on va
aller les voir c'est la bonne partie
de la part de la personne qui qui tente
pour le truc
malheureusement
tous les échanges sont juste gagnants
pour pour les noirs
un truc comme ça peut-être
avec le roi elle se cacher même c'est ça
qui a pleuré le roi blanc il coupe
l'attaque le pion et il bloque un peu
les déchets donc là je pense qu'on va
monter droite tranquillement vers C5
alors il va en baisser OK
pour essayer de me cacher dessus avec
échec essayer de
supporter la pression
[Musique]
on peut se faire vraiment tourner
pendant des heures maintenant attention
il y a peu de temps attention il faut
pas tomber faut pas tomber
pas la pendule véritablement en direct
et du coup
on n'a pas la vraie pendule on peut pas
voir d'ici malheureusement le temps sur
le sur la pendule sur laquelle pour
vibrer quoi à chaque fois
c'est 7 en tout cas il a l'air ouais
7-12 voilà ça c'est la bonne
c'est la bonne
caméra faut pas il faut pas qu'il bouge
là on est bien
donc la caméra a perdu la caméra a gagné
l'ordre
il y a pas de soleil en Islande
un peu plus froid en Islande
et
[Musique]
encore un échec là c'est dangereux cette
position il aurait dû passer son roi
peut-être tout à l'heure il va essayer
de le faire tout à l'heure et il l'a pas
fait et du coup là il laisse pas mal de
chèques
mais au fur et à mesure peut-être
réussir à montrer son bras quand même
je sais pas si il va réussir
dans ces 5
est passé comme ça
[Musique]
comment tu vas
gagner ça
un ami soit
alors
il y a pas grand chose à commenter on
tourne toute façon on n'a pas de risque
si il risque d'oublier la pendule mais
pour un joueur de cette qualité là
normalement il est censé la gérer en
plus il est rentré tranquille on voit
que il est pas stressé
[Musique]
il y a pas trop d'échec
ravageur
c'est risqué cette position à chaque
coup avec les Blancs vous prenez un
risque donc wesleo et il va insister
alors Magnus a fait à gagner contre le
fait de sayef vraiment prix de beauté
Naka aussi à gagner
on a dit une belle partie
[Musique]
qui a battu qui a battuaca et si je fais
roi dk3 c'est qu'à 3D 4 3 et 4 ça c'est
grosse performance de de Greta Arson qui
a tenu soit avec les Blancs après une
partie un petit peu
[Musique]
pendant la partie on n'a pas le temps de
penser à ça mais à froid s'il a perdu
cette première après ça peut être la
spirale de la défaite contre des joueurs
de ce niveau là
donc là c'est une grosse performance
effectivement pour pour démarrer doit
être content non c'est en plus bonne
partie alors j'ai pas compris du tout le
C5 de de
saut qui a joué juste avant
complètement foutu par contre
il va être perdant mais bon tu sais avec
peu avec quelques secondes
on les gâche bien de temps en temps mais
on pensait que ouais c'est ça allait
faire la différence dans ce genre de
position
et je vais vous mettre la caméra avec
je vais vous la mettre après du coup
alors il me semble du coup la partie la
deuxième ronde devait se jouer à 18h15
voilà il est 20 donc on est un petit peu
de retard je pense déjà sur la première
partie je pense qu'il va avoir quand
même un petit break de 5 10 minutes
je pense ouais donc on va se faire aussi
un petit break du coup
donc on se voit dans 5 minutes
donc on va lancer peut-être
donc dans 5 minutes on revient avec
Kevin donc restez là on va voir les
parties retours de Carl Seine fait de
seghef bluebom Nakamura
[Musique]
dans le deuxième on a donc à personne
saut et on a aussi
about torov contre nepoméachi
ont gagné très facilement donc on va
voir si ça se vérifie cet avantage avec
les Blancs
sur la gauche en direct ouais ouais
c'est ça c'est là
[Musique]
marrant de voir les les seconds qui
viennent
tu vois je sais pas
c'est plutôt rigolo là c'est je pense
c'est un peu plus détente
allez on revient en cinq minutes donc à
tout de suite rester parmi nous
lance la pub à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est de retour
bonjour à tous Pour ceux qui viennent
d'arriver et à ceux qui étaient déjà là
donc on va sur maintenant
partir du match faites aussi f4sen
on va suivre aussi
Nakamura plus Bob
nepo contre ados auto Rohff qui va
devoir se refaire
donc là par rapport au match qu'on a
enfin au résultat qu'on a eu dans le
premier match ma carte scène qui a quand
même battu fedo avec les Blancs donc tu
as quand même bon pas très surprenant
car c'est quand même en tête de soleil
numéro 1 qui est comme favori dans ce
tournoi
donc là il aura les Noirs contre
philosophe
on a un petit peu c'est parti qui ont
été vraiment archi dominés que soit
Carlsen ou abdosaurrav bah maintenant on
va voir s'il y a que les pièces noires
ils sont aussi faciles ce qui
m'étonnerait c'est ça
et après de l'autre côté on a Naka avec
les Blancs cette fois c'est votre
blueboum donc on a vu tout à l'heure
qu'avec qu'avec les Noirs c'était quand
même assez à cette difficile de prendre
l'ascendant et là on voit F4 qui a été
joué au premier coup mais on n'a pas la
bonne position
là j'ai l'impression que j'ai j'ai
[Musique]
pourquoi j'ai l'impression normale
je pense que
ok alors pourquoi j'ai la pourquoi j'ai
pas la bonne position
attends je vais faire comme tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
voilà
donc F4 D5 OK
et c'est la même partie c'est la même
position encore que tout à l'heure
pour le côté équité c'est très bien
OK
ça paraît pour le moment moins animé que
c'est plus posé
donc on peut imaginer peut-être que fais
dodo a envie de jouer un plan un peu
comme de la beurre tu le sais avec petit
rock comme ça
et ça c'est l'idée c'est pas du tout
mais il est en H1 donc il a pas le droit
donc
magie
[Rires]
[Musique]
il y a toujours cette histoire d'un B5
échec donc il faut se méfier on oublie
ce genre de coup
genre si je fais C5 dame B5 ça peut être
en béton
donc bon il faut que je prenne le centre
quand même il va falloir sortir la dame
si je veux faire un petit rock
ce qu'on peut imaginer kss6 pour faire
un jour le grand rock
il y a vraiment beaucoup d'options là
puisqu'on ne connaît rien on a déjà au
deuxième coup et d'ailleurs Magnus qui
peut jouer très rapidement et il est au
deuxième coup il a déjà pris une trente
quoi
ce qui est marrant c'est que les gens
vraiment réfléchissent quoi au deuxième
coup c'est pas du bluff ou par rapport à
ces analyses qu'est-ce que je veux juste
comme variante non c'est vraiment on
découvre la position ensemble et en
deuxième coup on réfléchit quoi et on
calcule ils vont chercher un schéma de
pièces un souffle un setup comme on dit
pour bien mettre les pièces quoi dans ce
genre de position
et c'est hyper intéressant de voir ça
parce que franchement
toi c'est quand même les meilleurs
joueurs du monde et il joue un jeu qui
est entre guillemets assez nouveau tu
vois et
il y a pas de théorie c'est juste
vraiment la compréhension des échec quoi
qui prime un peu de un peu surtout quoi
mais c'est important je dirais pour les
joueurs amateurs d'ailleurs d'essayer de
s'entraîner à non pas visualiser le côté
coup parcours mais un dispositif qui
valoriserait toutes les pièces et
prendrait le centre et permettrait de
roquer finalement on vise dans ces setup
tous les toutes les règles d'or que vous
connaissez bah ok bah c'est le moment de
les appliquer mon cavalier en G6 ou en
G3 par exemple c'est une mauvaise pièce
donc est-ce qu'il faut pas le passer en
f2d3 j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
c'est des questions comme ça que que
Magnus va se poser dans ce genre de
position et que son adversaire lui aussi
va se poser salut xD
salut ACTA salut à tous
donc parti
très très dangereux
très très dangereux ok
alors là ici c'est assez marrant cette
position parce qu'on voit qu'il y a eu
un G4 qui a été loué donc on va aller
voir un peu ce qui s'est passé une
Anglaise gros B C4 5 G4
partie et puis bon il est quand même
assez streamer donc je pense qu'il a
envie de faire aussi un peu spectacle
mais c'est pas très bête aussi tout pour
le côté cavalier H5 qui est la plus
mauvaise pièce de légitier on le met en
G3 et on le valorise donc finalement il
y a quand même un sens derrière
c'est que c'est une sorte de grobe vous
voyez sauf qu'on a pas le fond en G2 on
n'a pas vraiment les trous et le Caval
qui va venir ici en F5 ou en H5 donc
c'est pas c'est pas stupide comme idée
mais après bon je pense que il est aussi
un peu fantasque dans ses décisions tout
ça il aime bien
donc là j'aime bien ça coûte un coup
genre sûrement fait dans cette position
[Musique]
ça donne des tempos aussi après gfwef
cavalier G3 il y a rempois il faut aussi
se voyez l'initiative des deux joueurs
je laisse la pas faire tous les deux
français polonais OK
parle polonais alors
[Musique]
trois qu'avec ces 6 P3
comment il va jouer ici avec les avec
les blancs en aka on a l'impression que
les deux joueurs faut qu'on peut
peut-être faire le grand rock en tout
cas ouais
ça c'est clair faut pas oublier en fait
quand on voit la position comme ça on
fait un bilan photographique mais les
deux joueurs peuvent encore roqués quoi
donc faut pas l'oublier quoi
ça se fait visuel pas de tromper
d'ailleurs des deux côtés ça veut dire
que
ça c'est un truc faut pas zapper ce
genre de choses alors juste pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas bien c'est c'est
variantes d'échec donc c'est pièce notre
on a les pièces placées au hasard au
début de partie et donc bien sûr on a
une position symétrique c'est à dire que
les Noirs ont le même position que nous
au début
et l'idée c'est que si tu bouge la pièce
par exemple si je veux OK et ben le rock
il se fait comme on voit l'échec même si
la tour elle est en G1 au lieu d'être en
H1 je fais le petit rock moi fait deux
cases et ma tour passe en fin
donc pour ça il faut que la tour n'a pas
bougé que le roi n'est pas bougé comme
au vrai échec la tour elle est en géant
mais elle était placée en début de
partie donc elle a pas bougé encore bon
après roi D1 là il y a plus de rock
tu vois poser la question
après est-ce que c'est vraiment
quelque chose de bien pour Bloom je
pense que oui quand même mais c'est que
fouage 5 ben l'inconvénient de pouvoir
H5 c'est Caval et B4 qui vient sur C2
parfois 6 grands
C2 va être aussi l'idée des blancs et de
jouer avec un grand artificiel
la position à laquelle on peut fermer
pas forcément obligé de roquet moi
j'aime beaucoup les Noirs ici je te
l'avoue mais mais bon c'est de
comprendre un peu ce que vous faites
dans le cas
je pense que joue vite déjà pour mettre
la pression à son adversaire autant pour
l'instant ça c'est je dis bon il y a pas
la position est très très bizarre
donc voilà bon il essaie surtout de
jouer de jouer très vite et c'est pas
facile dans cette position pour bluebaam
de prouver l'avantage donc il y a
toujours des problèmes dans le champ de
position
et la pression sur le cash G6 il faut la
gérer on a envie de sortir le fou des 8
pour faire grand rock mais il y aura
trois qui va dégager le cavalier
peut-être qu'il va permettre fouber deux
comme tu le disais et sur foie F6 il y a
cavalier 4 toujours donc bon c'est pas
si facile il faut en fait j'aime bien
les Noirs moi aussi mais je sais pas
comment continuer
et par rapport au gaz blanche qui sont
un peu ouvert quand même ça a l'air
intéressant complètement
leur cases on leur menace et c'est pas
évident
en fait complètement d'accord sur le
bilan mais comment on continue
concrètement à fou au seat il a joué
fossette et on a vu tout de suite que la
Jauche est excitée donc il a pas il a
pas apprécié donc c'est que la position
était pas si facile que que cela a joué
clairement A3 cavalier ge4 finalement la
pression on va s'inverser comme des cas
c'est possible en fait
c'est possible parce que je me lance
quand même des coups comme A3 dessin ou
tu vois
j'ai pas envie de pousser devant mon roi
mais effectivement des fois on a le
droit on s'ouvre comme tu dis on a le
droit à tout au randoms en fait ça
bougeait
[Musique]
mais concrètement ça fait ça fait comme
des menaces beaucoup de coups candidats
même cavalier B5 et pas crétin enfin je
veux dire on trouve plein de cours à
jouer là
c'est drôle qui jouera des selles pour
défendre le pion
il y a eu à 3 qui était pas du tout cool
la jauge pour les joueurs c'est pas
juste
regarder par curiosité ce qui était
proposé par ordinateur
juste par curiosité F4 plus 1,5
absolument introuvable
qui aurait pu pour un nageur comme
Nakamura
mais j'ai pas du tout vu on n'a pas
proposé
qui m'a l'air bizarre visuellement que
tu vas même pas y penser et normalement
le chat aurait dû y penser parce qu'on
leur a dit d'ouvrir avec les pions
l'éruption la rupture voilà les ruptures
monstrueux parce qu'en fait il y a plein
de trucs de voir parce que c'est pas des
échecs vraiment modernes quoi et du coup
F4 c'est fort parce qu'on a qu'à en
termes de joueurs créatifs il est quand
même très très présent
c'est un des joueurs de créatif
donc ok donc
il va peut-être je fou B2 roi C2 il va
juste tranquillement comme ça et
peut-être même venir à pousser en fait
F4 donc préparer sur le long terme
la poussée
ça va maintenant qu'on a les idées F4 ça
paraît évident en fait si c'est ouf ah
ouais bien sûr bien sûr maintenant qu'on
le voit oui beaucoup trop beaucoup trop
influencé par ordinateur de manière
générale j'étais en train de regarder la
camstouf et je crois que c'est fait
d'ocef qu'il y a qui a fait un stonol
avec les Blancs contre
il me semble on
avait déjà vu le début rapide et
ok il a
on voit que c'est beaucoup plus modeste
qu'il a joué car il sait si ça avait été
joué d'accord
s
du centre
et aussi le coup cavalier G6 ils ont
compris en fait assez vite ces joueurs
là que le cavalier H8 et le cavalier
achat sont les moins bonnes pièces et
très vite ils s'en occupent ça c'est
vraiment intéressant pour les joueurs
amateurs je trouve dès qu'ils ont un
problème ces joueurs très fort dans leur
position bah il le règle et on s'occupe
toujours aux échecs de la pièce la plus
la plus bête dans son camp et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant
a déjà joué son cavalier en F2 donc ça
fait là trois joueurs sur 4
occupés très rapidement là de ce
cavalier mal placé dans le dans le coin
à un moment donné pour viser la classe
de 5 et après préparer un petit peu
[Musique]
5 x 4 est-ce que c'est un coup pour
manger le temps ou est-ce que c'est
débile
je suis pas trop savoir ce qu'on fait ce
fond en fait est-ce que c'est bien ou
pas bien
parce que je pense que les blancs vont
quand même vouloir faire le rock le
grand rock dans cette position petit
rock m'a l'air un petit peu compliqué
avec la tour en face
avec le vis-à-vis mais bouger les fous
ok ici et mettre un cavalier en 5 bon il
vient de du coup
pas de cavaliers 5 stuff
et surtout attention à E5 qui pourrait
survenir à n'importe quel moment si j'ai
fait cette robe quoi c'est clair que 5
ça peut arriver très très vite avec les
fous qui peuvent vite sortir
puis j'ai un roc hyper stable côté
côté grand rock avec les noirs et les
blancs le petit rock avec la colonne
gouverte peut-être mais c'est un peu
bizarre et grand rock maintenant avec le
petit poucet 3
on va le voir un petit peu nebomination
contre Abdou santorov parce que vraiment
avec les Blancs on doit absolument
gagner pour pour revenir dans le
dans la game dans la game donc là il y a
eu une petite française
quand même il joue pas vraiment comme
les autres tu vois il y a toujours des
ruptures un peu de partout et lui il
joue un peu plus
[Musique]
là il a sorti des fesses il a ok par
rapport à la partie d'avant
ça j'aime bien dessin donc on va
commencer à prendre un petit peu
d'ailleurs
on s'en occupe et on joue F4 on prend la
case à 5
une belle brique envoyé par abusa
c'est 3 le Fou est mal placé mais
peut-être que le temps est trop un jour
peut-être trompe pas les cueillir
3 plutôt que qu'autre chose et que c'est
quand même on est un peu coincé je peux
pas le C4 parce que c'est trop trop
faible toutes les cases qu'on donne
autour de
F5 déjà peut-être de laisser le pion en
mangeant ces deux c'est juste pas
possible donc en fait peut-être que
cette fois c'est le seul coup possible
même qu'elle va les prendre F6 je prends
c'est le roi très très
difficile
on peut gagner un pion après avec un F6
mais on n'est pas matérialiste avec les
Blancs quand le roi il est à poil comme
ça
ça fait vraiment très peur on pouvait
regarder si tu veux la vendre d'ailleurs
elle avait des choses intéressantes vous
pouvez peut-être donner la qualité en
plus avec les noirs sur toute la suite
là quand il prend F6 j'ai pris ces deux
échecs
pour apprendre puis on prend il faut
prendre et la damma 3 peut-être
j'ai pas mal de choses qui ont l'air
assez fortes
c'est pas mal aussi hein comme tu le dis
maintenant
[Musique]
que c'était quasiment plié peut-être
j'ai pas envie de le quoi peut-être
il y a vraiment beaucoup de choses
quand même je peux pas défendre parvenir
[Musique]
très très dur
position
[Musique]
je suis un peu taré je crois mais
je regarde la F3 ils sont d'un point
fermé
mais là je peux jouer cavalière H4 pour
me déclouer c'est ça que je veux faire
j'avais vu une idée comme ça avant
j'ai pas de mauvaise casse ça le
problème mais je voulais te faire tout
reprendre
et tu auras 8 mais j'ai pas de mauvaises
raisons en fait je peux pas me tromper
malheureusement
ok donc du coup sur Detroit c'est 300
obligatoire sinon on est vraiment on est
vraiment déjà qu'il est pas très bien
mais c'est peut-être moins pire
qu'elle est F5
d'ailleurs
c'est aussi l'idée de de contrer son
casse blanche
G20 ça semble simple
il est hyper créatif donc encore une
fois
derrière ce
couple aussi dans son style et
d'ailleurs
un jour jouer un petit à trois C4 pour
essayer de sortir ce foodcas noir alors
qu'ici la C4 c'est dur à faire ça donc
quand même pas mal de cases et à trois
c'est pas possible parce qu'il faut
prendre donc B4 c'est un coup assez
malin qui permet éventuellement à trois
C4 qui permet aussi de la MAF 3 et
peut-être B5 c'est clair donc ok à 5
direct je vais agressif
ça gagne vraiment un tempo donc je
trouvais ça assez légitime de gagner le
tempo et de mettre la pression sur le
Roi B7
comme on veut mais
maintenant bah je joue à 4
et 5 OK
oui c'est à cause de ce coup-là
j'ai pas de bonne case pour mon cavalier
cavalier F2
le fou va se faire dominer par le
cavalier va semblablement
les deux sont
des bonnes cases
ça va
et là
moins de simplifier la qualité mais bon
c'est pour venir en D1 je vois pas trop
dur
l'échange est imparable et ensuite le
café va venir soit ici ce qui va être
très très dur pour
pour néo qui a un mauvais fou et qui a
du coup pas de colonne ouvertes et les
noirs qui ont vraiment tous l'espace du
monde et plein de faiblesses le purin 4
qui est faible
il y a eu un boomerang parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'était une époque qui
mettait la pression ça avait l'air
brillant mais en fait
accepter cette pression et en fait il
avait vu un peu plus loin
vraisemblablement et très bien jugé
cette pause qui qui nous arrive salut
Andy cheese
es
donc ouais grosse grosse avantage ici
[Musique]
d'Abdou qui peut la coller 2-0 à un
épaule d'entrée franchement ce serait
vraiment une très très grosse intra
matière de armsteroff qui est champion
du monde je vous rappelle de partir
rapide
2022 et qui qui joue aussi pour être
champion du monde du coup Fisher random
ça serait quand même assez incroyable
qu'à 18 ans il est le double titre
champion du monde en tout cas je pense
que je pense que ben il est ça fait
partie des joueurs
pas dire grand favori mais déjà qui
peuvent clairement que la surprise
c'est pareil j'ai B1 pour moi le
différence du Fischer random chess et du
960 c'est la même chose mais deux noms
différents c'est juste ouais alors de
pas je crois que ça plaît Fischer random
ça c'est le nom de base qui avait été
donné à la variante après il y a eu 1960
je sais pas pourquoi mais au final c'est
c'est la même chose on va dire que
Madame
Cher random = cest 260
dans la position qu'on a il commence à
prendre du temps ce qui est très rare un
souffle souvent il est vraiment bien en
terme de temps donc c'est la c'est la
galère quoi pour lui c'est un peu la pls
donc du coup ben là il y a eu parce
qu'on avait dit donc faut se 5 et 8
océan
[Musique]
un échange en espérant que les Noirs ne
prennent pas F2 pour pouvoir bouger le
cavalier et comme il menaçait des trous
en plus bon bah c'est vraiment encore
plus tentant de
croquer donc prise qui avait des six
donc c'est 4 ça reste ça reste quand
même bien joué c'est 4 parce que
[Musique]
tu te fais pas en faire un comme ça quoi
mais bon ça va être difficile alors
cavaler 7 c'est malin ça empêche
cavalier ici sûrement que sur cavalier 4
n'est pas avait en tête de venir
balancer attaquer là-bas
là là c'est intéressant pour tout le
monde parce que
dans la position qu'il a joué dans la
partie là avec la mb7 il y a zéro risque
pas d'attaque et là il y avait ce risque
là et puis on sent pas la qualité
d'avance pour l'instant avec les cases
noires qui s'ouvrent et le roi noir qui
s'ouvre c'est même risqué j'ai
l'impression d'être moins bien tout de
suite bah là j'ai l'impression que les
blancs sont bien imaginons là je place
manger B6 et si je défends bêtement avec
croix B7 il y a plus on prend puis on
prend et tout c'est 6 déjà et ça arrive
très très vite donc en fait voilà nepo
avec cette idée de pouvoir attaquer
envoyer à quel point déjà ils arrivent à
trouver tes du contre-jeux à ce niveau
là c'est juste hallucinant
parce qu'il doit y avoir 960
possibilités oui c'est tout à fait ça
ils ont dit qu'il retirer si au tirage
au sort il y avait la position de base
que l'on connaît à notre position
fétiche de démarrage qui survenait voilà
donc ça fait 9509 positions possibles
pour se chauffer du monde c'est ça si
parce qu'on regarde pas je vous échecs
serait quand même
le comble mais voilà mais du coup
qu'elle va les baisser très très bien
joué de la part de du coup empêche ses
cinq donc je vais sur les cases sur les
belles cases que je dont je voulais
aller sans me faire claquer la tour en 4
donc parce qu'à la base on avait deux
cases on voulait venir soit en C4 soit
en E4 mais du coup venir en venir en C4
c'est plus possible après ces quatre qui
a été joué
et le cas du coup ben également avec ton
34 et c'est 5 qui est compliqué donc du
coup cavalier DS7 c'est 5 et hyper
normal et là j'ai quand même envie de
dire belle avantagement
très rapidement bah c'est foutu en fait
quasiment que je pense que c'est
je vois pas de contre jeux parce que la
qualité ici il doit pas intérieur
ce pion est trop fort il y a trop de
faiblesses chez les noirs et le Caval
qui arrive en C5 ça va être aussi
vraiment difficile
et même peut-être jouer simple je veux
ça faire G6 mettre le la tour en D8 en 8
pardon et mettre le cavalier aussi en 4
associés possible mais bon dans MP4
c'est quand même la menace numéro 1
apparaît et déjà c'est très très dur
donc je pense que déjà de base
un époque qui peut être à hautain direct
enfin c'est pas l'émulation mais bon si
par 2 0
dans du premier match préciser parce que
sinon Robinson il serait venu directe
direct ok non mais l'idée c'est vrai que
quand tu perds de zéro pour les matchs
tu es pas favori pour qualifier quoi
donc je vous rappelle que les les deux
premiers de chaque groupe se qualifient
pour la demi-finale qui auront lieu du
coup je crois samedi et dimanche depuis
final et final
donc dans la poule numéro 1 on a
quinzaine fedosaief avec Blue baume et
Nakamura donc Carcès pour l'instant 1-0
pour 45 bonbonne Nakamura c'est 1-0 pour
Nakamura et dans l'autre poule on a
appstorev qu'on nepo qui du coup à 1-0
pour à nos autographes qui est en train
de de
mettre la pression un peu dans la
deuxième partie déjà et deuxième partie
on a Greta reson le joueur local grand
maître à 2530
contre so Weasley donc il y a une nulle
dans la première partie et
donc voilà
derrière là on va peut-être travailler
il y a eu des il y a eu des trucs on va
aller voir si tu veux les maths
le joueur est très très joli en plus le
match avec
le roi qui va finir en B4 on va aller
voir rapidement ce qui s'est passé
regardez donc on a 6 donc la partie on
peut avoir très rapidement depuis le
début juste pour voir ce qui s'est passé
voilà là on voit tu vois encore sauf
comme on avait dit une ouverture très
rapide de la part du meilleur joueur bon
du favori de la la partie et puis
souvent ça fait mal
dès que les filles c'est quoi l'idée
se retrouve très très vite en
tuant
[Musique]
les épaulettes ouais bonne partie pâtes
et sur quoi prend ici on a tout réel roi
là d'un échec et voilà
première partie mais il s'est fait
bâcher sévèrement sur la deuxième règle
noire donc on pensait que ça allait être
dur pour lui déjà il a il a il a réussi
à faire nul en se battant bien dans la
première ronde mais c'était mais ça ça
promet ça va être dur quand même hein
ce tournoi il va être long pour lui
parce que
il y a pas de clients
c'est quand même trois du top mondial
quoi et bon lui les grands maîtres il
est très fort mais bon il y a quand même
entre son statut de grand maître à lui
et les autres c'est juste le jour et la
nuit franchement
c'est très difficile c'est pas les mêmes
à partir de 1600 on avait dit super
grand maître de 1700 super super grand
maître c'est super super voir la vie de
mondiale quoi donc c'est top mondial
contre
top combien 3 400
il y a vraiment une grosse différence
j'aimerais bien les regarder
si tu veux
[Musique]
ah il est 475
quasiment 500 mondial quand tu joues
contre top 10
[Musique]
il est top 30 40 à peu près mais bon un
champion du monde de
rapides il a il a 18 ans il est hyper
chaud c'est
costaud quoi donc
voilà d'ailleurs alors je te rappelle
que enfin c'est que nous à chaque fois
qu'on stream ensemble et ben on se donne
des petits Paris pour un contrôle il va
falloir qu'on trouve et donc moi je j'ai
un petit Paris si tu veux sur gretharson
je sais pas c'est pareil combien de
points il fait dans le tournoi
pas mal
il lui reste encore
quatre parties
[Musique]
il lui reste à jouer un époux en
aller-retour et à Boston
combien il va faire de points sur sur sa
poule
moi j'ai une idée
si tu as la même que moi je parie
après une nul ça reste clairement
possible mais après tu encore une fois
c'est pas les vrais échecs parce qu'il y
a pas la théorie c'est un peu différent
donc du coup la chance de faire une nul
tu vois là il y a une seule nul sur
toutes les parties alors généralement
quand même alors tu
bon allez moi je dis qu'il tire une
nulle
temps et là il va se réveiller là
d'ailleurs attends
la dernière fois lors du stream que que
je t'en parlerai je me pendant que je
t'en parle
tu sais qu'il y a les matchs team France
là avec chaise.com je sais pas si tu as
déjà vu
c'est quand c'est à chaque fois je crois
que je reçois une notif ouais c'est une
fois par semaine le week-end
généralement donc c'est le vendredi soir
le samedi soir ou le dimanche ça dépend
et ça dure une heure et demie à peu près
et
du coup et du coup bah écoute c'était
chaud moi je moi je joue quasiment tout
le temps et on est on est plusieurs
streamers à
on va dire streaming événement et du
coup c'est hyper cool et il y a des
discussions assez fortes et là on est on
est en tête dans notre groupe et si on
gagne le groupe en gros et bien on va
monter en ligue supérieure ils ont
supérieur l'année prochaine et là par
contre c'est hyper chaud quand l'année
dernière je me faisais à chaque fois
quoi genre je veux des grands maîtres ça
donne envie c'est intéressant
c'est comme à chaque fois c'est dispo
il y a trois cadences c'est tu as le
Bullet une plus une tu as le Blitz 3
plus
une ou deux je sais plus non 5 + 2 le
Blitz pardon et le rapide 10 + 2 et en
vrai c'est intéressant et donc en tout
cas je t'enverrai les je t'enverrai les
notifs dès que je les ai dès qu'il y a
des des trucs donc tu vois GB 4400 c'est
un des tas de mine de la team France
donc généralement quand il y a un truc
et bien
en vrai pourquoi pas j'aime bien jouer
comme tu le sais après je sais que c'est
trouver les dispo en ce moment surtout
comme je te le disais oui oui c'est un
peu compliqué mais je t'écrirai et puis
tu me diras en fonction de toute façon
j'avais promis
tout dépend de la régularité parce que
finalement on voit enfin moi je le vois
de plus en plus quand on fait des
directs comme ça qu'on a de plus en plus
de de propositions diverses et variées
que c'est difficile de tout suivre en
fait
des fois c'est le vendredi des fois
c'est le samedi dimanche ça dépend
vraiment mais voilà bon en tout cas
à titre perso juste pour expliquer aux
gens j'essaie de pas me charger le
weekend parce que déjà en semaine je
fais je fais vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
et puis bon c'est toujours pareil c'est
discours de vieux mais bon c'est que
voilà ma conjointe et ma fille bon au
bout d'un moment l'histoire de stream ou
des chèques tu vois elles sont elles en
ont bien
marre et d'ailleurs du coup j'ai dû
aller à l'accrobranche pour faire passer
tu vois l'histoire de du stream de la
des trois jours qui était pas prévu tu
vois
[Rires]
je me suis bien débrouillé à
l'accrobranche pour ceux qui veulent
savoir on veut des photos on veut les
photos je mettrai une vidéo si tu veux
sur insta il y a eu des bonnes vidéos tu
peux les mettre sur discord aussi
discord
déjà je vais je vais les mettre sur un
stage chez faire tu sais
ça
c'est cool
pour les grands matchs pour les gros
matchs
sur la pépite qui vient se prendre des
bonnes raclées tu sais ben en fait si tu
joues ben peut-être moi je peux jouer au
deux tu vois je peux faire décaler moi
je suis un peu le client bon en fait ça
va j'ai pas des mauvais résultats pour
l'instant mais bon on a pas encore
d'équipe trop trop forte enfin j'ai vu
des maîtres filles de Max quoi non mais
j'aime bien en plus j'aime bien faire
pas mal de trucs de petits de petits
événements tout ça donc c'est c'est bien
tu vois ça mais c'est sympa en plus
c'est de plus en plus de monde et on est
quand même beaucoup à streamer et c'est
vraiment sympa salut à tous pas tous il
vient de temps en temps il vient m'aider
pas touche il est bah tu connais pas
touche je pense non
donc voilà il vient tourner avec moi
c'est cool
voilà salut à toi pas de touche alors du
coup cette cette partie en s'est arrêté
tout à l'heure on s'est arrêté à un
petit
ah ça y est mon chat qui arrive ça
risque de manger la table
nos contraintes
donc
je ferme la porte il va défoncer la
porte
ça a l'air pas mal ce que faisait Magnus
et il a laissé visiblement quelques
petites plumes
comme il l'aurait voulu ou faire quelque
chose là il est bien fixé
elle te dit bonjour Patouche Fatou aussi
alors fous des 6 du coup moi j'aime bien
ce que Manu
c'est pas si facile peut-être je peux
préparer encore non je suis pas pressé
[Musique]
du coup surprise qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire exactement
j'ai raté la modération
on parle mal de mon chat donc
elle prend E5
puis on prend juste le four
F2 on prend quand on veut
il a l'air
il a l'air un peu moins bien Magnus
maintenant comme ça
avec e D6 et D6 ouais
bien bien trouvé un de la part de fedo
qui va finir par gagner en fait la part
de faux
échanger un peu aussi la structure de
pion
donc prise tout revenu pour améliorer sa
position stratégiquement voilà donc
c'est marrant c'est tout F2
depuis tout à l'heure j'aurais joué G3
comme ça je me serais dit j'ai plus de
problème et j'aurais essayé de taper le
pion le top taper le pion ici ce qui est
peut-être bien défendu en tout cas il
veut jouer avec G4 du coup c'est ça la
super idée
c'est dur à trouver hein cette cette
catch je trouve que ça c'est incroyable
j'avais pas vu que tout était parti
là c'est la bagarre
mais ouais du coup tourgé un c'est pour
jouer G4 je pense mais c'était
extrêmement dur à trouver quoi enfin si
je sais pas ouais bah ça peut être que
ça je crois
j'ai 4 pour contre la case du cavalier
peut-être
tu vois c'est rigolo et puis il y a une
très belle séquence qu'on peut voir sauf
cavaler ses 6 et X4 de fait d'obs pour
essayer d'échanger faux compte cavalier
en fait à terme on aimerait bien jouer
le cavalier contre le fou ici dans cette
position avec un fou passif à la défense
du pion ici quoi donc en fait ici les
Noirs vont aimerait bien essayer de 5
mais c'est quoi ton impossible de jouer
5 à cause de la pression un roman qui
exercent sur la case de 5 et du coup
regardez c'est 6 fois 4 c'est hyper
intéressant que tu lis un peu manger le
cavalier c'est là qu'ils sont super
forts Cavalia cavalier A5 de Carlsen
quoi donc ils ont une lecture des
échanges qui est juste phénoménale et
sur faut prendre
maintenant faut trouver quelque chose de
concret parce que on doit être mieux
mais pas si facile encore de
combien
je pense il veut un cavaliers en C6
parce que c'est pas grand chose au final
je pense que le cavalier est mal placé
en 4
qui sera un jour attaqué non
pas étonnant il y a eu B3 alors il y a
eu ce fameux G4 après
tourisme
depuis tout à l'heure il voulait
valoriser il a été vraiment fort autour
de cette thématique de jouer avec G4
j'avais pas pensé nécessairement moi si
tu veux tout j'ai envie de faire j'ai
trois effectivement je
je n'aurais pas profité de majorité de
contraintes et là si j'arrive à faire H4
et G5 c'est top alors là il y a une
petite tactique bien sûr cavalier E5 si
Dame prend V4 qui gagne la Tour Eiffel
etc
franchement c'est un j'aime beaucoup
l'idée parce que c'est des exemples
compliqués de jeux avec les pions et
franchement bravo c'est la grande classe
moi j'aurais
bêtement je pense fais G3
essayer de prendre la colonel tu vois
c'est là que tu vois qu'on se ressemble
tout enfin parce que c'était ce que je
voulais faire tout à l'heure qu'on a
fait tours géant même déjà au 19e coup
sur dame G7 je pensais à G3 pour voir
juste tout feu tu vois le côté en plus
naturel défendre les pions avec les
pions
et puis tu as la colonne tu as
l'avantage comme ça
ça m'énerve de mettre mes pièces de les
rendre esclaves tu vois et du coup
vraiment ce coup G3 je pense que je me
serais parti est-ce que tu veux bien
mettre juste un instant souffle le 18e
coup noir juste pour voir à ce moment là
sur dame G7 mais vraiment de manière
machinale j'aurais joué G3 c'est sûr
les pions avec les pions tu vois je me
dis c'est tellement naturel en plus
cavalier H4 ça semblait
tu vois un plan comme ça assez standard
quoi je pense que c'est pas une gaffe
mais je trouve beaucoup plus infantile
ce qu'il a joué regarde la séquence tout
rêve 2 tours géant enfin tu vois c'est
la police c'est pour ça qu'on joue enfin
on dit des fois malheureusement pour
nous avec Steve qu'on joue pas le même
jeu que ces mecs là c'est clair
là c'est vraiment le top top niveau hein
et Magnus il a il a un certificat
kalashon c'est une gaffe vous étiez fait
exprès
tant qu'à faire tu peux manger les pions
non
il a oublié peut-être
ça quand même
prendre 4
ouais mais c'est quoi la différence de
la foire
de l'avoir gardé peut-être il veut que
personne il a pas longtemps
il a fait une tête mais des mauvais
jours les surprises qui avaient les B4
comment tu défends juste
[Musique]
la partie a continué
il a mangé il ajoute un project 4 ok
mais
donc du coup il a quand même un pion
pour la qualité
et des idées avec cavaler les cartes
mais bon
je pense que Laura blanc est quand même
assez safe ici peut-être un petit rappel
[Musique]
du coup je t'ai mis sur la sur la 8e
donc pas très très loin de tomates quand
même même dans F4 c'est peut-être très
bien
donc là il faut regarder même 80 alors
bien 3 BD aussi à l'air très bien
mettre le roi tu as publié chaque et
après tu peux continuer tu vas
tranquille quoi
une partie un peu plus bizarre que
d'habitude il a pas été aussi dominant
qu'il ne l'est certaines fois ouais mais
est-ce qu'il a vraiment gâté
quoi mais ça m'étonne quand même ça
parle ouais ouais ça c'est vraiment gros
c'est un truc qu'on voit en une seconde
parce que quand tu fais G4 tu vois que
sur un point qui évaluation alors du
coup son terme G6 cavalier
comment on finit là il y a plus qu'à
finir Dame des trois était proposée par
super looping ça a l'air très fort aussi
qu'il y a du dame B5 du damashat c'est
ce qui se passe
il y a eu des trucs je pense pas
madame Detroit en tout cas c'est quand
même embêtant
c'est multi menace
après en pratique tu vois
après Dame des trois ça peut être le bon
coup mais il faut faire gaffe que je
puisse pas de piquer le pion ici
en fait juste l'idée de
remettre le roi à l'abri pas de la
contre-jour tu vois tu te caches je
pense que le coup humain sera
belle
du coup ouais voilà il faudra revenir
c'est un peu dommage on a l'impression
que c'est quasiment le cadre
encore
précis on doit pouvoir finir le
[Musique]
la réfutation là
et après
parce que le pion il peut être
si mon cadeau
[Musique]
donc OK
intéressant est-ce qu'on va le voir un
peu ce qui se passe chez nepo voir s'il
arrive
[Musique]
pendant que je vois que Nakamura
on s'est arrêté
par là
[Musique]
la manœuvre la part vraiment eu de
problème
puisqu'elle va les prendre j'ai 5
F3
il y a des problèmes parce que du coup
tu as quand même une pièce en l'air tu
as le cavalier cataclato et aussi la
dame que tu as pris cavalier donc
cavaler des quatre forces
et après prise prise et je prends F6
donc là plutôt une bonne position pour
les Noirs j'ai l'impression parce que le
roi blanc quand même assez faible
je pense
plutôt sympa pour les noirs
il a pris la nuit direct
ouais ouais bon il y a un petit Edge
psychologique aussi
Nakamura sa grosse star ou baom dans
dans ce tournoi là
aussi doué qu'il est bah ouais il avait
besoin peut-être de sécuriser même nul
quoi c'est ça
un peu ce qui fait contre les autres
pour l'instant il va surtout Batman news
vraisemblablement
ce qui s'en sort parce qu'il avait une
sacrée poubelle tout à l'heure
alors attends on vient il a réussi à
sacrifier la qualité pour s'activer et
c'est là que tu vois qu'ils sont forts
les mecs parce que franchement tu as une
pollution qui est complètement injouable
qui il a l'air de quand même bien
réussir à la tenir
[Musique]
15 et 5 il y avait sûrement
un truc comme ça et essayer de mettre le
foulard et de monter le droit et
peut-être d'amener la tour ici et même
pas se faire
[Musique]
mais dans la partie que l'on avait vu
c'est à dire sur 5
[Musique]
et là
un peu plus ouvert mais
alors
j'ai B6 quoi
pour pas permettre cette manœuvre de
floupions S7
on pourra le jouer quand même après en
plus donc du coup
on a piqué le pion
e
c'est un petit pressing blanc en fait
cette position c'est clair qu'en fait
l'impression que qu'elle n'est pas en
train d'enverser un petit peu en
attendant cette partie très très jolie
sacrifice alors que Abdou Santoro je
trouve qu'il avait fait une grosse
partie
avec les Blancs
ont réussi largement à compenser la
qualité mais il y a quand même une
qualité d'avance donc ça va juste faire
mieux
extrêmement vite extrêmement bien donc
que va-t-il je suis vraiment pas inquiet
pour nous on serait plus inquiet avec
stouf mais n'est pas on lui fait
confiance il a encore 3 minutes donc
donc
et mais par contre il a plus de tour
donc ça m'a l'air bizarre ce qui fait il
veut manger là et pousser le pion
ah oui pour aller prendre à 5 refaire
roi B5
parce qu'au final en fait les noirs avec
les pions pas de
genre ça ça
tu vois je peux pas t'inquiéter puis
encore
ouais mais la problématique c'est ça
c'est à dire comment je fais maintenant
vraiment là j'ai plus de coup
j'ai l'impression que ça va perdre
[Musique]
joliment
discrètement après tu peux jouer ah oui
j'allais dire tu peux prendre trois
quatre maths
OK et là on bouge plus du tout on bouge
plus du tout avec les Blancs bah c'est
pour jouer ça autant pas jouer là
alors comment on gagne ici d'amener
3 donc je te reprends en trois sur ce
qu'il fait bravo
finish bah il a juste donné la partie
n'est pas alors qu'il était pas obligé
tu peux me montrer le moment sauf le
moment clé là où il décide de ils ont
répété la pollution plusieurs fois tu
vois ouais c'est ça il y a eu des
répétition un petit peu bon ok est-ce
qu'on fait nuit de ce qu'on fait pas
mieux là
et puis dépôt a finalement pris le pion
ici allez vas-y je joue bien mais je
pense que n'est pas rater ça a dû être
roi-satis
ça a dû être sympa parce que au final si
tu veux voir là-dedans quoi
c'est que tu peux pas pousser le pion
Laura parce que il y en a tout le temps
ici
et le pion il avance pas et en fait du
coup tu as rangé j'ai besoin d'un tapis
de pièces là je me mets la prise et
pousse et après faut bouge ben
maintenant j'ai tout rembout qui gagne
parce que je menace échec croix bouche
et roi champion et si à foue 3 ben je
mange trois et je fais des en fait donc
du coup tu as pas le choix et là je
prends pion ok tu vas manger ici mais
peut-être trop là voilà et je prends ici
voilà
trois contre trois à ce niveau là c'est
juste perdu voilà tout va montrer sa
puissance et du coup
est-ce que on peut aller voir Magnus
pour voir sa résistance
[Musique]
passivement c'est un peu moche le
cavalier qui sort un petit peu
c'est difficile
et je vois même pas un échec qui
pourrait faire avec le noir c'est
et maintenant comment on passe avec les
Blancs parce que c'est quand même pas si
facile
que ma tour elle a pas de case
alors
la pâte case mais elle est pas vraiment
prise pour l'instant parce que je crois
qu'il y a aussi c'est vrai
mais du coup dès que tu me fais un
chantage ah oui dès que tu me fais un
chantage sur
dame 1 je te fais un chantage aussi
avec Dame G7 ah non je peux pas donc
j'ai pas de chantage parce que
tu as pas malheureusement le roi là
parce que
faut regarder et tu me laisses le pion
des cartes quand même en l'air sauf donc
tu as ce côté-là
ça donne et là je pourrais peut-être
faire un dame G2 de folie pour commencer
à essayer de te contrer c'est chaud
quand même madame G5
c'est chaud
très chaud
non plus
de la pression des quatre honnêtement
j'ai du mal à gagner cette position
[Musique]
ça change rien
comme on n'a pas trop parlé mais sur
dame 4 par exemple faut vérifier un coup
comme dame géant
discret discret souffle
[Rires]
c'est les blancs qui jouent pour le gars
mais peuvent très bien se prendre les
pieds dans le tapis quoi non mais il a
dominé toute la partie et
la courbe donne 14 pour les Noirs mais
c'est juste c'est impossible c'est un
bug
mais
non
de jouer ils ont gagné plus le roi il
est bien
je peux pas être perdant aussi si je
fais tout rêve 5 ah oui non non je dis
une bêtise peut-être
je voulais gagner le pion h en force
mais je peux pas
si
il y a pas tout F7 puis 8
tours
parce que sinon ce serait différent mais
la dame est quand même
on a fait dam F4 premier coup
je pense qu'il a pas le choix de toute
façon parce que si il joue pas comme ça
parce que c'est risqué même
ça peut-être que il a pas vu comment
gagner il est arrivé chez pendant un
moment il reste limite à la pendule tu
vois au final il faut jouer un coup quoi
c'est dur hein en plus bien
en fait ouais peut-être que son roi il
va lui quand même lui donner la case B4
donc sur keprend des cartes je crois que
c'est le coup quand même ça et là il y a
plein de choses il y a cavalier C2 dame
G2 il y a dame G1 et dame G5 non mais
c'est Dame G5 le coup qui me fait le
plus plaisir parce que je tape la tour
et en plus il y a le KV qui peut arriver
donc
je le garde pour après ça fait peur en
tout cas
beaucoup de jeux
à 8 ça attaquer la tour dans la vente
avec 4 leur dit qu'il est revenu
actualiser parce que ça me paraissait
bizarre qui donne plus besoin de plus
perso
je pense
à l'air d'être plus ou moins seul coup
après baisser son avarelé mais je pense
que les Noirs objectifs sont quand même
mal donc
donc il doit essayer de créer quelque
chose avec les Noirs je pense s'il veut
pas perdre je pense que B6 s'arrête
peut-être d'être une mort lente tu vois
genre je vais revenir ici mettre un
petit peu
parce qu'au final après ça tu as cours
de cou
et à plus tu vas finir à être un peu à
court de coup
il y avait la menace d'échec et de
manger à la tour
donc 3 B2 je t'aime pas
et là il va peut-être le temps
est-ce que échec et damocal ça peut être
une menace non je pense pas la finale
elle a pas l'air pour les noirs
[Musique]
il a pas voulu je me questionne pour
après pourquoi quand ne fonctionnait pas
m'intéresse
pour avoir après avoir imposé
compliqué pour Féder d'avoir les nerfs
de
gagner cette partie
4 c'est chaud
se trouve
que c'est 25 secondes
c'est un peu ce sera un fail quand même
de
de jouer ah non le roi est venu en D3
pardon il arrivait en Détroit
je pense qu'il aurait pris la bulle
quand même
[Musique]
un petit peu en décalé là avec la vidéo
je vais vous mettre la vidéo en plus
grande d'ailleurs peut-être que ça va
être
ça peut être plus sympa
vu qu'il y a plus beaucoup de
[Musique]
je pense niveau la finale ça va être
perdu
[Musique]
à 5 d'abord et faire tourner ici ça
risque d'être gagnant pour pour les
blancs parce que ça c'est immobile j'ai
un pion qui H qui partira sûrement la
pollution qui a l'air difficile à tenir
je pense
[Musique]
ça va être son idée du coup si je fais
attention
voilà par exemple
et chaque pas le choix il vient ici il
passe par derrière
[Musique]
peut-être que faiso il aurait dû essayer
de prendre la nuit dans sa position je
sais pas si c'était possible de jouer
pour la nuit dans la finale
maintenant il va finir par essayer de la
jouer
pourquoi il est pas mangé 6 minutes
peut-être
attends
il trouve que la très mal joué donc il a
arrêté les fraîches je pense
à la fin il peut peut-être essayer de la
gagner non
genre genre G6
c'est bizarre qu'il n'est pas tenté
enfin la caméra on sentait que c'était
presque consenti mais c'est pour
l'ensemble de son œuvre je pense qu'il
est pas très satisfait c'est parti
la partie de manière générale parce que
tu veux jouer stuff
[Musique]
je pense que je vais arriver avant tout
il a pas voulu avec en fait comme il y
avait 20 secondes salut fuckley
comme il y avait 20 secondes contre 7 si
ça se dit bon
j'ai fait un ennemi j'étais complètement
foutu ouais je pense que il a préféré
assurer là ici et ok on va on va
s'arrêter là donc en tout cas appartient
juste ce qui se passe sur Caval et prend
des quatre tout à l'heure on a on avait
regardé c'était intéressant sur dame 1
je mette pour voir
meilleur coup
c'était le meilleur coup la dame G7
dames
G5 aussi on avait cité j'ai 5 ou tours
à 8
parce qu'au final
ça c'est plutôt compliqué là il revient
un petit peu entre les morts dans cette
partie et la tête pas pas voulu prendre
tous les risques
comment
fait d'ocf n'a pas gagné aussi il y
avait peut-être un moment où il pouvait
gagner bien avant parce que la cavalier
F5 est vraiment très fort un moment il
avait toutes les pièces au moins ou
quand tu te rappelles a donné sa qualité
sans le vouloir réellement c'est au 27e
couche je crois qu'il y a un truc
bizarre
voilà il y a eu le moment où il a donné
apparemment c'est il y a pas tous
maîtrisé vraisemblablement
apparemment c'est pas bon enfin c'est
difficile la rue des bons coups toi même
si c'est pas très précis
[Musique]
dans l'idée tu mets ton à l'abri quoi
après
mais oui mais en fait il jouait la
finale à chaque fois avec deux et
ok du coup il a raté quoi vraiment pour
essayer de gagner alors je crois que
c'était pas du tout un bon coup mais bon
c'est une période complètement
envie de le faire et ça a l'air comme
hyper hyper normal et
qui sont qui ont l'air assez évident
mais au final je trouve B2 il a la
position elle est plus claire après
cavalier F5 apparemment et ici c'est
compliqué quoi
voilà c'est égal à peu près c'est un peu
pour les blancs mais
[Musique]
f Il a pas trouvé il a essayé de faire
souffrir bon c'est bien ce qui est ce
qu'il a fait donc finalement on a vu la
brillante victoire de Wesley saut donc
un ennemi sur deux contre Gret Arson
nepo abdosa torrent bah il a pris double
bulle du coup donc 2-0 pour abusent qui
s'inscrit la grande surprise de de cette
ronde un assez rare à 2-0
et ensuite et ben tu as 45 qui prend un
et demi sur deux contre fait de sayef et
sur deux contre Booba voilà et
maintenant on va avoir le choc juste
après la pause c'est le grand choc
Carlsen
Nakamura ça va être vraiment sympa à
suivre ça sera le grand format je pense
tu l'as choisi souffre tu l'as coché
alors attends
si tu veux donc
pourra se refaire contre Greta Sarson
[Musique]
du coup voilà double match confrontation
d'ailleurs notre pari c'est toi tu
paries sur zéro sur 4 et moi je
moi je pars rien de mis comme ça tu vois
je me garde les résultats
même si spontanément j'aurais dit comme
toi 0 sur 4 mais peut-être que Yann va
m'aider merci Yann donc
le deuxième match de la poule A ça sera
ouest les sauts contre Abdou satoraf
Nadia Beck c'est un gros match aussi et
dans la poule B on a
qui sera un joli match mais moins
alléchant que le Nakamura Carlsen dont
je te parlais en partie aller-retour
ça marche
salut à toi non mvl je parle toi
malheureusement
non on a besoin
on a bluebom on a fait le CF il y a du
beau monde on a pas de français pas de
mvl pas de fille Rosa et pas de Bacro
enfin pas de français quoi
voilà donc nous on va faire une petite
page de pub là 5 minutes et on revient
direct après donc restez restez
connectés sur sur le stream on revient
dans 5 minutes à tout de suite à tout de
suite à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes revenus sans Kevin si
avec Kevin voilà je suis là
par rapport à tes compétences musicales
franchement je crois que tout le chat te
remercie de ton choix pour la musique
et du coup tu as eu pas mal de petits
messages en ce sens et ben écoute avec
plaisir donc ceux qui veulent la musique
je vous l'envoie en MP
facilement justement les volontaires
n'hésitez pas à me contacter par la
musique c'est une de tes compositions il
me semble c'est ça
non vrai malheureusement on choisit pas
c'est des musiques qui sont imposées par
chetcom alors
tout à l'heure je l'ai écouté et il est
vrai que je suis assez content de ne pas
avoir à la subir tous les jours
contrairement à vous
mais voilà alors du coup les joueurs qui
sont pas encore installés je sais pas à
quelle heure ça va reprendre donc
normalement ça va ça arrive assez
rapidement quand même ils ont un quart
d'heure de retard à peu près
ok donc ça devrait arriver un testament
ouais ça devrait arriver
et du coup donc on va voir des beaux
appareils non tu m'as dit qu'il y avait
4 scène Nakamura
qui avait aussi
so a besoin
ce qui mène le 7
donc ceux qui a battu qui a battu
[Musique]
gretharson par un et demi zéro et demi
qui joue contre off qui a gagné 2-0
et après on va avoir de l'autre côté des
baumesnées à qui perdent de zéro contre
catharsonne qui lui a un demi
complètement voilà et de l'autre côté on
a quinzaine contre Nakamura donc Arsène
qui a gagné avec un point et demi sur
deux en fait c'est marrant ils ont pas
fait exprès mais j'ai gagné au match de
perdants dans chaque cool donc du coup
match assez important quand même
pour les gagnants quoi pour s'assurer
vraiment une place en finale
en demi-finale plutôt
et
donc voilà je vous rappelle que les les
deux premiers de chaque pool se
qualifient pour la phase finale donc
demi-finale et finale qui auront le
samedi et dimanche donc pour l'instant
ma saut et même la danse dans leur
groupe tandis que personne Naka mène
aussi la danse dans leur groupe
donc là les deux leaders se jouent donc
c'est important c'est intéressant
qui sont pas encore pas encore sûr de
passer
[Musique]
parce que un petit dépôt qui peut se
réveiller derrière ou
donc c'est encore compliqué encore
beaucoup de choses à faire
il me semble aussi stouf qu'ils avaient
un quart d'heure là pour tu sais on a vu
pas mal à la pause je pense que vous
allez regarder aussi les caméras on a vu
les secondes en de différents joueurs
arrivés et il y a eu le tirage au sort
de la position parmi les 960
possibilités donc la position a été
tirée et du coup après les joueurs
discutent avec leur second temps de des
choses à faire c'est la prépa la mini
préparation voilà à l'ancienne j'ai
envie de dire est-ce que les joueurs ont
le droit d'avoir je pense pas je pense
qu'ils sont tous
scannés tu vois
par les métaux tu sais et du coup est-ce
que les joueurs ont un ordi ou pas ça
c'est intéressant un petit quart d'heure
pour pour bosser mais bon ça arrive
d'ailleurs ils vont ils arrivent tout de
suite tu vois un petit quart d'heure de
retard qui arrive donc ils ont ils ont
comment dire
[Musique]
tu pourrais passer aux zapping avec un
truc comme ça normalement sauf aux
happiniens je crois qu'on est fatigué
déjà pour moi à partir de là c'était
plus facile
mais il me semble
il me semble que par rapport à la
position qu'on va avoir et ben les trois
premières pièces sont exactes non
non parce que j'ai vu que le roi était
entouré par les deux tours je crois que
c'est roi E1 tout F1 tourner un quelque
chose comme ça
complètement tilt je crois pas
je préfère parler encore aller dans ton
sens pour mieux t'enfoncer tout à
l'heure stouf j'essaie d'être alors je
vais essayer d'actualiser encore c'est
apparemment c'est le truc qui marche
chaque fois OK
vous allez voir qu'apparemment la
position s'approche ouais c'est ça je
vois donc
il y a une dame dans un coin ou dans un
dans l'autre coin là en fait
j'ai 15 ans je pense mais attends
l'appariement c'est bien
[Musique]
car tu m'avais dit non
normalement
j'ai 4 personnes d'accord
ça trompe pas c'est bien la caméra
ça a été joué ok on a la position bon ça
y est vous voyez le roi était entouré
par les deux tours
ça ressemblait vraiment à la position
classique
[Musique]
c'est vis-à-vis ça perd en un coup
et d'ailleurs ça fait penser à j'avais
vu un DVD de Nigel Davis sur l'anglaise
il y a très longtemps il a il avait
l'introduction ton DVD c'était qu'il
avait joué d'anglaise contre short que
la partie c'était genre C4
un coup
genre cavalier G3 B6 vous prend à 8
c'était la partie contre short et
il a dit qu'ils avaient 7 ans tous les
deux et
[Rires]
[Musique]
le génie quoi tu prends des cavaliers
au début je crois que c'est fermé mais
alors du coup là il faut pas jouer
par l'analyse tu vois
je me suis dit mais c'est pas mal quand
même
il joue je sens qu'il fait comme ça
regarde
cette Poker Face que j'y crois pas quoi
Nakamura c'est pas c'est pas un bleu
mais c'est pas mal leur petit délire là
ça commence fort
là c'est du délire pur franchement
donc vous avez vu hein stuff maintenant
il enlève le pion d'œil il pique la Casa
H3 pour pour Madame mais là je fais
moins le malin quoi donc il faut que je
bricole un truc avec H4 mais je vais pas
aller chercher du coup
salut Serge salut si oui mais même même
Naka je pense qu'il se marre de la
position ah oui bah évidemment
[Musique]
à tous les deux
depuis maintenant tu vois sur internet
ce qu'ils ont joué etc je pense qu'ils
sont bon délire quoi
à ce niveau là et je coupe B3 D5 c'est
quand même un beau troll quoi
et en vrai c'est un bon coup j'ai parce
que
s'il faut jouer
tu vois bon après je peux changer de ou
des 4 ça va quoi tu vois
non mais ils sont où les mecs parce que
en fait ils viennent de préparer ça en
fait Naka il s'est dit je vais sortir
madame vite parce que donc B3 j'empêche
le foie je suis de sortir et il était il
était pas préparé là dessus c'est sûr
c'est génial ce qui est génial c'est que
tu dis non mais attention les gars pas
faire G6 parce que du coup bah on perd
le fou mais lui non il s'en fout il joue
juste cinq quoi juste c'est un super
grand moment d'échec quoi fantastique de
Random c'est ouais ça c'est c'est ouf ce
qu'on voit là
un truc comme ça quoi
et qu'après il joue genre
non mais psychologiquement c'est marrant
quand même tu vois de
[Musique]
de jouer ça et d'ailleurs Naka il
scotche un petit peu puis tu as envie en
terme d'ego de pas de pas laisser quoi
c'est
est-ce que je peux jouer fou prend d'un
point
B6 et G4
c'est quand même drôle
ce serait drôle
qui contrôle
malheureusement la blague ne marche pas
à l'envers vous voyez parce que du coup
je suis parti il y a pas le fou comme
tout à l'heure ok bon marrant en tout
cas la petite
non mais écoute tu vois moi je vais
faire l'artiste là je vois il joue B3 G5
bah j'ai envie de le faire aussi de mon
côté quoi tu vois hyper marrant en tout
cas ça part bien franchement ça passe
bien je suis sûr que tu as qu'à y a
pensé quoi il aimerait bien faire pareil
regarde merci regarde regarde il attend
ça chauffe ça chauffe
ce serait génial franchement ça j'avoue
que que psychologiquement c'est c'est
c'est ouf ce qu'il avait 45 parce que
Naka joue B3 pour essayer d'avoir de
diagonale il se prend j'ai 5 qui marche
et après l'échange des fous bah c'est
lui qui jouait 6 quoi et en fait
psychologiquement vu la vitesse ils ont
préparé
ouais je pense qu'ils ont regardé un
petit peu ce que là mais en fait ils ont
ils ont trop réussi à lire d'un cas quoi
avec ce petit B3 quoi c'était sur V3
savait enfin
le meilleur coup de la position quand
même sûrement sûrement mais après c'est
un coup hyper hyper
bien
on va montrer pour végarinos en fait
c'est un piège question d'un point ici
on fait manger la dame ouais avec
cavalier F6 découverte et sur dame G7
sole case tour G6 attends j'ai eu pardon
et damage 6 6 tours G6 la marche 3 et je
m'échappe et du coup ici après D5 le
full contre la case de la dame et en
fait tourger c'est imparable et la dame
elle est
qui enferme une dame je passe ça dit
quelque chose mais
Éric prier
comme ça mais c'est une partie où il est
je l'avais invité à manger
comme ça et puis finalement bon il avait
réussi à venir etc j'ai pas réussi à
l'enfermer mais il y avait un thème
comme ça je connais bien et d'ailleurs
dans la française aussi il y a des idées
comme ça dans la wunawa tu vois par
exemple
intéressant en tout cas mais là le coup
j'ai 5 c'est juste énorme quoi c'est
génial
c'est vraiment génial
[Musique]
il a fait
4 écrit et je me suis dit non ça y est
là
ok F4 ok
c'est ce qu'on voulait voir des parties
très romantiques celle-là déjà
bonne soirée à toi Serge à bientôt
peut-être que ça va se stabiliser salut
Serge pourquoi
on travaille sans ordinateur
juste pour voir ce qui se passe sur oui
parce qu'il y avait quand même des
pièces de prises on a les piquets
on a les piquets dans la vente de
condamné pas mal de matos
au moins et là H4 j'imagine pour ça
faire la mission sauvetage de la dame et
surtout G6 HD quelque chose comme ça
[Musique]
et en gros tu prends là et tu as mangé
quand même tout pion pour la dame donc
pour ça va 5 points un fou ça fait trois
et un pont ça fait ça fait un donc ça
fait 3 + 5 + 1 ça fait 9
donc en fait matériellement les Blancs
ont quand même pas mal de pièces c'est
pour ça que c'est pas si intéressant bon
ça reste quand même avantage noir mais
c'est pas non plus un truc de ouf c'est
juste avantage bien il va sûrement
gagner mais ça se barre quoi
[Musique]
que 4 a été joué
alors on peut pas manger
c'est un pion ou pas ça
je suis en train d'essayer de comprendre
la petite carotte alors
je comprends pas pour être un territoire
peut-être que juste
à surveiller quand même toujours
mais il y a dams
ouais j'avais peur de me prendre d'âme 5
mais peut-être c'est rien du tout qui
peut être chaud
j'ai un très très joli mat elle vous
fait un match fourchette
après ça c'est une première idée du coup
dame c'est plus précis ici il y a
quelques cavalier à 7 c'est pas simple
qu'est-ce qu'il ajoute en scène
et il a mangé sur échec du coup je pense
qu'il va jouer
de couleur basique
cavalier 2 les Noirs font G3 même pour
bloquer le foie H1 retarder je sais pas
j'ai trois c'est un coup qui que j'aime
beaucoup en tout cas
ça va être le côté blanc le prochain
coup ça va être G3 suivi de grands rock
et en fait le blanc ont l'initiative
donc pas mal d'attaque et le roi noir il
est un petit peu mal placé vous voyez
que le foot 15 blanche il a disparu
petit rock va être très dur à faire
parce que j'ai pas de pionger grand rock
va être parce que j'ai pas de foutu en
keto donc du coup en fait il veut jouer
avec le avec l'initiative G3 quand rock
etc et en gros ici j'ai trois qui a
proposé Kevin ou un instant cavaler est
interdit parce qu'il est cloué et sur H3
bah en fait du coup tu as bien pas mal
de monde devant le fou et le fou il va
être beaucoup de temps à se développer
et pendant ce temps là peut-être que je
peux du coup
mactifier
essayer de faire ça en tout cas c'est
hyper intéressant j'aime beaucoup ton
coup de G3
juste par curiosité est-ce que
l'ordinateur vous éteint et dingue je
trouve aussi je trouve c'est à quel
point Naka qui connaît pas la position
on en est sûr
hyper vite
c'est clair en disant feeling je pense
qu'il y a assez et ils font tout ça
vraiment les genres de très haut niveau
ils arrivent à filer des pions en disant
je pense qu'il y a assez on verra bien
et c'est hyper intéressant parce que
c'est pas facile cette position donc la
scène va penser à G3 ou pas quoi je
pense qu'il a pensé ça c'est surtout
tout de suite parce que
parce que
c'est intéressant après ce qui va le
faire je sais pas en tout cas j'aime
beaucoup ton courant c'est hyper
pédagogique comme comme
match bonne soirée à toi
que je suis assez d'accord avec toi
c'est hyper intéressant mais ça on était
hyper content avec tout de commenter ce
tournoi là pour le côté un peu délire
des échecs sans théorie
il participait ce sera encore autre
chose il participait à ce type de
tournoi en tout cas à notre niveau avec
avec Souf mais
en tout cas commenter de voir les idées
de haut niveau cette qui est totalement
dingue je trouve dans ce qu'ils ont
pensé et le petit quart d'heure aura
suffi à l'équipe de Carlson pour pour
délirer quoi avec la position
je me disais bah ouais je fais rock et
après et après
je fais ça mais en fait je parle
cavailler à chaque fois non pas très
malin du coup mon coup
j'ai trois petits Rogue enfin Madame non
il y a pas d'histoire comme ça
franchement et presque un monde et il y
a presque un monde où il a joué
Magnusson
où je pourrais
donc il a joué du coup
il a gg3
j'étais moins inspiré en
enlevant en faisant une petite
connerie technique
non rien
j'ai juste
j'ai perdu l'écran j'ai des pneus à ce
moment-là
les mecs c'est exactement le genre de
variante qu'on voulait
ça c'est vraiment le match que tout le
monde attend depuis longtemps et
franchement les mecs ils nous régalent
parce que là il y a eu chez 4 elle est
complètement dingue il a joué G4
cavalier projet 4G3 je filme mon pion
mais ouais je te le refile et j'ouvre
mon fou c'est super bien joué mais quand
c'est une améliorer un peu son cavalier
dans cette partie c'est que vous voyez
franchement
n'a qu'à donner un pion pour
car ça ne le rend pour empêcher
l'initiative et n'a qu'à le prendre puis
le rang en fait on va juste c'est
excellent et
c'est hyper bien ce qui fait hyper beau
quoi
je préfère les blancs dans cette
position
je préfère les blancs aussi mais c'est
pas évident ok parce que j'ai mon
cavalier en l'air à chaque fois
je peux pas ok j'ai mon cavalier en
l'air mais tu avais des belles idées
souffles est-ce que là je peux pas plus
réalisable je crois pas parce que déjà
de un madame toujours aller en B5
heureusement parce que sinon ça marchait
peut-être
bon on va voir hein
voilà non mais c'est vraiment pas clair
d'aller se prendre ce cavalier de j'ai
du mal à cause de ton idée d'ailleurs
c'est toi qui me l'as donné
on avait pas regardé 5 mais c'est hyper
chaud que le roi en D6 il y a dame
Descartes non ça marche pas on peut pas
tout reprendre cette gagne
tout 1 et Dame des quatre sur roi des 6
terminé
donc ton idée tu as vu le piqueur
d'idées
merci
pour la Master Class du coup
j'ai réalisé après donc voilà si il
arrive à
je préfère largement les blancs et il a
réussi à le faire a priori parce que
possible
il doit être content Nakamura à la
partie code chez complètement d'accord
avec toi déjà c'est bien fou F3 mais
franchement le coup qu'on a montré avec
tout droit c'est beaucoup plus
d'initiative et ça gagne directement en
fait
juste ta ta petite initiative quoi
ok l'ordi apparemment on voit la joie du
coup moi je préfère ne pas l'avoir mais
apparemment il y en a plus qui préfère
la voir moi j'aime pas trop la jauge
mais comme a dit Serge une fois
d'ailleurs dans dans un stream il disait
ouais mais en partie on n'a pas la jauge
donc bon bref on est on est au
commentaire et vous on suit les pros
malheureusement
[Musique]
du coup on n'a pas le choix mais en tout
cas franchement
je vous le dis voilà jauge comme tout le
monde mais je préfère vraiment jouer
avec les Blancs s'il y a une facilité de
jeu qui se dégage de la position et et
du coup vous voyez si on regarde juste
la jauge Magnus a joué un coup déjà il a
perdu un petit peu par contre c'est très
intelligent le coup qu'il a joué en
pratique en fait c'est rentrer du rage
pour les Noirs parce que je me rends au
centre petit rock ça coûte difficile à
faire parce que j'ai plus de Pioneer et
grandes ça coûte très difficile à faire
parce que j'ai plus de foot casse
blanche et là tout est ouvert chez les
chez les Blancs il y a les colonnes il y
a les diagonales j'ai le bon fou enfin
un salaire très très dur pour les Noirs
en pratique donc là attention si ce
drama 3 il y a ma du couloir avec ta
main à maths donc du coup dans ma vie
c'était malin ça permet de changer les
dames
c'est magnifique
aussi après je sais pas ce que tu as
maintenant
oui j'avais pas trop le choix en fait
caresser trois c'est forcé
peut-être mais avec roi B1 tu veux juste
ça
ouais je veux en fait si vous voulez
pour moi mon cavalier à cause de
l'échange que j'ai du matos en moins
donc je le bouge pas
donc j'enlève ma dame mais après il y a
le maton 1 donc je peux toujours pas je
peux toujours pas bouger mon cavale donc
pour pour vraiment pouvoir
enlever tout ça il faut que je parte
trois temps
qui permet de perdre du temps qu'il a
trouvé ça
est-ce que je peux pas jouer un coup du
style aussi alors peut-être tour 1
c'est pas laquelle
je suis pas sûr
quand même
[Musique]
tu vois franchement c'est très scout
d'une immense qualité mais jouer ultra
rapidement aussi c'est vrai qu'on a pas
dit mais ils sont rapides les mecs ils
sont juste ouf enfin c'est vraiment
génial quoi après dans chacun gagner
leur match ils sont chacun hyper favoris
numéro
tu vois en fait c'est les meilleurs
joueurs du monde mais en plus c'est créa
c'est super sympa
de jouer de voir et en fait et ben ils
sont hyper contents tu sens enfin tu
sens qu'en fait et ben ils sont contents
d'être là quoi ils sont contents d'être
là et il s'amuse quoi hein ça c'est
important complètement
donc vraiment la cadence elle est
vraiment cool quoi
comme tu avais dit tu places la tour
face au roi c'est logique en tout cas
c'est le pressing augmente
peut-être du coup comme ça
encore j'ai du jeu souffle oui
peau avec B4
[Musique]
on va voir mais
D4 c'est intéressant pour vous faire en
fait essayer d'ouvrir et ramener mais je
suis pas sûr de ce coup parce qu'après
Beckham B5 cavalier à 14 bloquer un
petit peu comme la poésie il y a
toujours cette problématique
une fois que je bouge le cavalier
et ensuite une fois qu'on a préparé tout
ça voir si on peut jouer cavalier 5 voir
si tu veux jouer peut-être même cavalier
B5 des fois voir si c'est peut-être
ramené aussi la tour
rigolo puisqu'on est sur des cours
rigolos c'est D5 avec les noirs pour
casser la diagonale du foot casse
blanche
et tu ok qui est marrant parce que du
coup si je mange là je suis toujours en
maths ça passe en vrai
tu veux fermer la position en fait par
le fou quoi ton fou j'aimerais bien
qu'il s'active pas je pense qu'il y a
roi B1 et que c'est un peu bancal parce
qu'on damassi c'est roi B1 on voit que
c'est un peu bancal au niveau de mon mon
Roi noir c'est à vous que ça me fait
peur de toucher au pion de case blanche
quand même en fait eux aussi sur aura
peut-être F5 en plus comme thématique
blanche pour réouvrir la position et du
coup je pense qu'au niveau du jeu de
pions c'est pas tout à fait propre
l'idée sympa à montrer pour essayer de
jouer contre le footclasse blanche
puisque je n'ai pas de foot case blanche
avec baignoire donc dans le jeu de
couleur on essaie de fermer la couleur
mais bon c'est très dur pour répondre
[Musique]
alors
là on joue enfin c'est des échecs bien
sûr elles sont plus là du monde de
Fisher random en fait Fischer random
c'est quand elle est pièce qui sont
placées un petit peu au hasard en début
de partie une variante du jeu d'échec en
fait c'est pas le vrai jeu donc tu vois
là le roi et les tours pas placé sur les
cases naturelles de débat et du coup tu
peux roquet si tu as réussi à enlever
les pièces qui se trouvent
entre le roi et la tour d'habitude
je fais comme ça et pouvoir petit rock
il faut que je bouge lui et lui enfin
surtout lui d'ailleurs le
cavalieres
normales du rock c'est pas pas prise
quoi et après tu perroquet donc c'est un
peu spécial c'est un jeu un peu mais ça
ma région comme ça moi on m'a pas pris
comme ça moi à l'école
normalement tu as plutôt
tu as plutôt raison
donc là il s'est passé plein de choses
là franchement c'est une partie qui fait
malheureusement pour le spectacle
avec un petit
cavalier V5 de Massis pour et 2000
défenseurs du pion à 7 non mais tu as
raison
après c'est imparable cavalier
donc A5
ok donc on peut imaginer que Caval et
était une menace ici pour fixer un petit
peu la position et finalement les pièces
blanches pas forcément
et au final après
donc il mange un pion
[Rires]
[Musique]
tu sens pas quoi
même dans B5 qui va arriver avec ça va
arriver là maintenant on est on a trop
de problèmes sans doute
ça fait un peu peur quand même de mettre
en visite dans l'esprit je suis étonné
qu'il est simplifié parce que
envie de voir ce coup là enfin à titre
perso j'avais envie de voir
j'ai pas assez
ouais
la Tour de France
B1 quand même
dame ceci c'est peut-être très embêtant
ouais c'est ça mais dames et 6 je menace
Damas 8 je menace tout E7 ouais voilà et
là je tiens le cavalier donc Dame des
deux Robins
les pièces sont bizarres
donc là du coup j'ai rendu pion oui et
bon j'ai quand même
ça fait plusieurs trucs à surveiller
[Musique]
donc pourquoi pas peut-être que si ça
simplifie tu vois
non on sent que ça là alors maintenant
je vois bien une belle nulle maintenant
tu vois ça c'est un vrai
mais justement c'est pour ça que je suis
un peu déçu de la décision de Nakamura
c'est une décision forcément voir au
niveau de la jauge ça s'excite pas mais
je trouvais qu'il avait l'initiative
qu'il a un peu perdu alors oui
structurellement les blancs sont mieux
mais à court terme il y a une belle
initiative c'est les noirs qui l'ont
maintenant des plus belles pièces sauf
je pense que c'est pour ça que tu
préfères
fort et puis mon roi qu'il a c'est
solide tu vois je rabaisselle tout va
bien et alors ton cavalier ben il a pas
beaucoup de cases bon déjà de 1 il est
cloué parce qu'il y a un match mais même
si je joue à B1 et puis après tu bouges
en cavalier ben tu as pas vraiment de
bonne case éventuellement mais tu vas
toujours être chassé et puis tu as
bloqué tes tours enfin on sent quand
même qu'il y a un petit problème
de pièces
et puis aussi avoir un jour un tour 8
qui peut arriver
[Musique]
parce que je vois pas trop ce qu'il a vu
c'est bien
bon c'est comme ça comme ça mais
maintenant bon c'est plus
[Musique]
je pense que les Noirs ont une petite
pression moi parce que je peux peut-être
faire des coups comme damocrate déjà
sauf pour essayer de calmer la pose
ouais mais je peux refuser peut-être
ouais mais tu refais encore si je te
harcèle là je rejoue d'un mot cette par
exemple
c'est pas trop le jeu mais
je pense ouais tu vois ça pourrait être
une ça peut être une nulle rapide
franchement la partie était géniale la
partie était géniale vient de se calmer
méchamment
après bon là c'est les deux leaders qui
se jouent ils ont gagné un match après
mal ils sont pas forcément
besoin de faire en ligne dans cette non
mais c'était parti pour franchement
c'était
parti pour mais au final bon on a qu'à a
préféré calmer le jeu et car samedi
[Musique]
parce que c'est un des une des autres
grosses parties quand même
en tout cas c'est compliqué aussi c'est
un gros bordel
on va passer rapidement juste pour ce
qui s'est passé dans le début
OK
du coup comment
préparation enfin il a du monde autour
de lui
un standard à tout ça
[Musique]
à cette standard chez les Noirs les
Blancs un peu moins
c'est pas très standard tout ça mais ok
5 4 donc là il veut offrir la diagonale
ça ce qui va ce qui va réussir à faire
en fait dans la partie cavalue donc là
ça a l'air dégueulasse mais oubliez pas
que le rock est toujours possible
donc il y a eu 4 donc vraiment c'est un
genre qui est vraiment très actif il
aime bien poser les pions hein mais il
s'est fait contrer son 4 c'est un peu
concret sur le sur le cavalier F6 là il
a mangé ici
et tout reprend et puis on prend et
maintenant le fouet un petit peu en
difficulté là il a les manger et 6
pour gagner la pièce alors juste il se
passait quoi sur
la tour
du coup du coup il a fait à l'envers il
a joué Tourcoing F6 mais il faut prendre
avec un prank
et on est là
donc depuis
il y a plus de tours donc le Rock sera
interdit
et puis j'ai quand même des cavaliers
qui peuvent aller au centre alors moi
j'aimerais bien mettre un petit cavalier
sans sa case noire tu vois
ça pourrait être sympa à ma cavalier par
là je pense ça va être l'enjeu un peu de
la partie les
sauts qui va essayer de faire un truc
comme ça
pas évident
à ramener tout ça
mais la dame elle a un petit peu
hors-jeu il y a encore des jouets mais
bon comme tu regardes un petit C3 en
fait les finales sont gagnantes pour les
pour les blancs GPM de pièces pour la
tour et s'il y a plus de dames je peux
facilement faire Roader d'eux et
progresser au centre mais pions au fur
et à mesure un petit peu de travail
encore
la finale non la finale c'est facile
en tout cas il faut encore progresser il
faut encore être précis avec les blancs
mais ça a l'air en tout cas bien parti
pour ça ici
donc plutôt bien
est-ce qu'on va voir un petit peu ce qui
se passe chez notre ami fedo
qui joue bluebonne
ça que j'aime bien vraiment dans le dans
le Ramadan
il y a que des partis folles en fait
très souvent c'est la disposition des
pièces n'est pas on trouve pas des
structures que l'on connaît et tout ça
donc du coup j'aime beaucoup ces idées
là
très vite en fait ce qui se passe sur
les joueurs voient leur pièce mal
placées et c'est les activer et ce qui
est pas forcément le jeu au centre quoi
ils ont trop d'objectifs à réaliser donc
du coup ça donne des parties un peu un
peu vaseuses dès l'ouverture quoi
encore un thème mine de rien on a vu les
joueurs activé cette diago
il s'est fait complètement pigeonner
dans le début en fait
sur cette diago en fait il a perdu le
parce qu'il en fait
le jeu
qui bloque là donc c'est pas la même
chose oui la différence entre le fou P2
ici et le fou B7 ici le fou noir est
bloqué en fait par le pion dessin donc
pris ce qui va le prendre
et la foudre des câbles cavalier dominer
complètement c'est ça qui va ouvrir la
diagonale il a bien raison et F3 pour
bloquer la dame mais attention au max de
vidéo ça peut arriver
et bon c'est un peu bizarre parce que là
il a donné les pièces
qui fait une attaque double
et une fois que je mange là il y a
encore une fois les pièces en prise
mais ça va pas l'air d'être avant on
pouvait pas jouer juste pour des 5 au
lieu de Dame des 4
je mange quoi
comme ça au pire pas d'avoir des bonnes
pièces ouais en fait je vais essayer de
faire échec moi alors attends tout de
suite parce que je suis pas obligé je
pense là comme tous les bonnes pièces tu
as envie de me faire ton truc donc fou
des quatre
tiens mon pion c'est 5 et j'ai un petit
fouet 2 maintenant que tu m'as montré ta
menace en rétro à souffle je verrouille
ouais ça avait l'air quand même parce
que le cavalier A4 il est pas reluisant
là
je me suis dit au pire
ok de toute façon toute façon le roi
noir il est c'est lui en fait qui est
faible mon roi il est encore des cases
donc
tout ça ça va
donc qui est parti compliqué
je te regarde avantage mais parti
compliqué quand même bien sûr pas simple
tout salut comment tu vas bonsoir à toi
j'espère que tu vas bien
[Musique]
tu l'avais je pense voilà ouais c'est ça
exactement
il y a eu un jeu de diagonale un épaule
il veut une partie normale en fait
de se dire ouais je suis plus fort aux
échecs donc on va jouer aux échecs c'est
pièces
il peut vite être enfermé un jour bouger
le cavalier et jouer F3 c'est ce qui
peut se passer
cavalier B4 attention
il perdait la qualité
et j'ai 5
j'ai 5
[Musique]
je vois pas trop
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a cru
peut-être
prochainement
[Musique]
il y avait sûrement
mon sac degré tarsan là il va il va
sauter vite fait hein si il continue ses
prestations mais il a les Noirs c'est
dur avec les Noirs franchement on ferait
pas mieux il a quand même réussi à faire
à faire mieux qu'on va se et après la
dernière et tu vois le truc c'est qu'il
a déjà deux minutes contre 12 les mecs
jouent comme des piles électriques n'est
pas
[Musique]
ah ouais d'accord je me suis mais bon il
y a déjà il y a quand même il y a quand
même 10 minutes d'écart
et puis ils sont quand même difficile
[Musique]
F3 on sent qu'il va se faire
il a perdu la pièce et je la position
qui est juste abandonne après
et abandon
d'accord ok ben logique hein j'ai plus
que trois chances pour
ton seum après c'était à d'autres idées
franchement n'hésite pas d'autres idées
de Paris chercher je cherchais
de faire un gros pari sur la victoire
finale aussi ah oui bah ça c'est clair
demain on fera le petit comme ça on peut
réfléchir notre côté et on peut ouais on
peut faire donc la victoire finale et
aussi
le meilleur classement or
Carlsen et par exemple et on enlève
ouais on enlève ouais
on se fait un classement des dans les
deux poules et puis tu calcules aussi
il peut je pense
les deux aussi on voit que les Noirs le
cavalier la tour le roi tout le monde
avait l'air ses pièces
comment je fais parce que j'ai ma tour
D5 en l'air il faut prendre le 5 et
après
[Musique]
parce qu'avec toi la menace d'un point
bien sûr
je comptais revenir en fait tiens il a
mangé et scorpion prend est-ce que je
peux jouer cavaler 5 plus tard
donc j'ai quatre un point F7 quand même
j'attaque
sur le peut-être qu'il a vu ça je pense
ça doit être
ça a pas l'air d'être génial
donc du coup on est obligé de faire
mais je pense que j'ai juste à me
prendre
je peux avoir des 4
je sais pas si c'est bien mais c'est une
variante OK
intéressant quand même
mais on va dire que juste qu'on arrive
en finale car le scène va réussir à
délier les pions de Naka
et ça pourrait se simplifier si on perd
nos différents pions isolés sur l'aile
sur les lois après le 4 contre 4 à la
dame c'est archi nul donc faut faire
faut faire la différence
sur les droits là pour les deux joueurs
et bon sans doute que c'est vraiment
assez égalisant à un moment elle a perdu
un petit peu de sa saveur cette partie
il a l'air très cool je crois qu'il
regarde des parties sur le grand écran
voir ce qui se passe à côté là il y a
rien vraiment enfin pour des joueurs de
classe là sont peu inquiets
[Musique]
de la dame donc ça commence à
je pense que c'est le coup le plus
[Musique]
plus simple
parce qu'il fallait trouver une solution
après ouais
comme tu l'as dit là
du coup
[Rires]
je suis pas sûr que Magnus choisissait
cette voix de la nul non non là
un petit délai avec la caméra donc tour
reprend d'en prendre c'est la partie il
y a eu dans le 5 il y a eu Dame des 6 et
là elle est revenue
un peu désagréable
je fais du mal à bouger mes pièces mais
bon peut-être
donc c'est clairement pas terminé cette
histoire on dirait un pressing comme
Magnus les aime avec les Blancs
à
échanger des pièces tout est à mecisse
peut-être c'est un coup
au revoir
ça peut être un coup
on prend et voir si
ça vaut le coup de changer
alors attends ça joue
ok ça c'est actualisé donc là du coup je
pensais à ça mais après j'en sais rien
parce que la prise ici après peut-être
tu manges là
je mange ici quand même je mange là j'ai
un plan passé mais bon
j'ai un peu du mal à croire que les
noirs sont mal ici non non mais je pense
pas je pense il y a un petit pressing et
que ça devrait faire nul
je pense que les blancs sont tout à fait
ouais je pense que ça ça c'est bien
parti pour faire nul
est-ce qu'on entendrait pas me suis
pire des meilleurs l'antijeur comme on a
dit il y a l'anti jeux qu'on est mieux
au niveau matériel et quand l'autre a un
petit pressing on enlève les pièces de
l'échiquier aussi les simplifications
pour aller chercher la nul
en fait tu as pas besoin de prendre des
risques tu as une position
pour voir où ça en est yes alors du coup
nepo ça a fini il reste fait donc été
compliqué et aussi il y avait ceux
contre Abdou sur satorov on s'est arrêté
je sais plus trop il y avait eu un voilà
très important
[Musique]
[Rires]
une belle position pour le noir ici qui
a pas réussi à
se
protéger là il y a du Tour c'est un qui
arrive même manger à 7 sur mon goût
é
[Musique]
mais on sent que tactiquement
il peut se passer des choses
il peut se passer des choses ici
mais encore une fois justement
[Musique]
le roi noir et pas bon non plus parce
que j'ai plus de plus et en plus depuis
plus et ben je garde quand même
l'activité je garde les je garde
l'activité je garde l'attaque de mode
quoi donc c'est vraiment en pratique
peut-être que c'est le meilleur coup
c'est plus simple donc là ça devrait
rapidement c'est chaud qu'est-ce qui se
passe donc
bravo à toi
si jamais il arrive à se cacher avec son
roi encore une fois ça va être difficile
parce que cette position ouais la valeur
quand même très mauvaise pour les noirs
[Musique]
qui se cache par ici ah tu vois il
cherche l'embrouillant et c'est très
bien il a raison parce que il est il est
il a une qualité de moi
il faut jouer actif
et peut-être d'en prendre des trois il y
a des cavaliers en l'air il y a plein de
c'est marrant quand même de voir cette
position parce que j'ai quand même trois
pièces pour la tour les pièces le Kaia
A3 est trop mal et les cavaliers il est
perdu mais
[Musique]
mais
chaud quoi comment on continue
[Musique]
il empêche quand même ça
et moi progresser quoi c'est toujours
des positions quand tu progresses tu
peux te prendre les pieds dans le tapis
quoi tu vois cette partie qui la jouer
contre contre Google
je sais pas si tu l'as vu
si en fait il était foutu pendant très
longtemps et il s'est battu battu battu
battu et il a fini par l'embrouiller
ouais ben on voit qu'il faut plusieurs
il faut gagner quand on joue bien
évidemment et maximiser le le fait de
bien jouer mais il y a aussi les moments
où c'est plus dur c'est ça elle fait un
peu penser à ça tu vois dans l'idée en
fait c'est compliqué et
elle est blanche sont priori mieux ils
ont ils ont de matériel ils ont plus de
pièces ils ont des réseaux de maths qui
veulent arriver à très vite avec les gaz
noire etc mais il y a un roman qui se
balade et en pratique c'est pas si
simple alors ça va se vider ça va faire
ce qu'on avait senti la caméra ça
proposait de l'huile donc très peu de
coups
on peut y aller en voir si vous voulez
mais bon ça va faire nul facile
là il répète ils vont serrer la main
dans quelques secondes je vais vous
mettre le
temps de mettre la grande position voilà
on avait dit un petit ça se décanter à
on les a vu c'est parti là plus
plusieurs fois on connaît il restait des
petites chances à le roi mais dalle dame
il y avait vraiment rien donc ça se
bloque le 4 contre 4 voilà rien de rien
magnifique franchement de loin la plus
jolie partie le plus jolie début très
créatif c'était c'était fort
les deux hommes ont fait vraiment vibrer
dans cette partie
alors du coup il reste encore une seule
partie pour eux tout à l'heure à 21h il
me semble
mais il y a un petit déj
21h30 ou pas dire
alors du coup roi E2 a été joué ici
et donc tour des 6 il continue à
embrouiller sur cavalier 5 qui a tout
réussi ce qui qui
pique la dame
comme on continue ici moi j'aurais fait
Wave 3 tu vois mais
ouais on peut peut-être faire attention
quand même des embrouilles de partout là
ça marchera pas je pense
c'est pas très loin de marcher mais
intéressant en tout cas moi j'aime
beaucoup ce joueur avec les noirs qui se
battent c'est parti il se bat énormément
[Musique]
comme ça et ben il peut clairement
mettre la pression au nord en fait non
franchement avec les Blancs je saurai
que je suis largement mieux mais tu as
vraiment peur de passer à côté ici
j'aime vraiment bien parce que du coup
ça me permet de d'être compact et de ne
jamais en fait blender quoi
tu vois alors que là enfin moi tu les
boules là je blender je vais essayer de
m'en fous en prise
en fait
pour l'ordinateur peut-être que le coup
le coup de Wesley so est meilleur mais
pour nous je comprends tout à fait ce
que tu dis le côté prophylactique de
d'anticiper d'avoir les pièces plutôt
protégées pour pas perdre quoi très
souvent tu vas rater une tactique avec
par exemple regarde pour prendre des 5
faut prendre que chaque est d'apprendre
par exemple tu vois bon ça marche pas
parce qu'il y a des fois ce genre de
thème quoi
il y a beaucoup de thèmes alors du coup
B3 ça va l'air quand même très solide
ouais c'est safe et à la dame bouge par
exemple ben maintenant tu menaces d'un
échec et d'un point F7 parce que tu as
le fou qui va défendre avec toi et bon
peut-être qu'il y a des trucs comme ça
j'en sais rien mais dans les folie dans
l'état en fait mes pièces se défendent
donc tu vois j'aurais préféré faire ça
après c'est ça reste une question de
goût là les joueurs commencent à être
fatigué mine de rien l'enchaînement etc
même pour eux c'est ça reste difficile
je peux bouger mon roi mais tu vois
c'est bizarre d'avoir cette pièce clouée
tout ça sur dame 3 il se passe quoi il y
a tout reprend là non
et c'est nul en fait
c'est juste
égal ça
[Musique]
me semble
un moment donné
non mais c'est un peu long mais à
l'usure
la dame en D3 et en tout cas il est
vraiment fort techniquement aussi
et donc bon je pense qu'il va la gagner
je pense qu'il va la gagner
comment tu progresses
parce que dès que tu bouges
qui peut qui peut arriver peut-être Dame
des trois
donc là
faut pas oublier un thème A4 à 5 un peu
tête aussi à un moment
pour essayer de déstabiliser la défense
elle va avoir comme deux fronts
et tu as les thèmes sur le roi donc la 4
à 5 c'est assez
assez intéressant parce que là je
contrôle beaucoup de cases
mais il a fait H4 de l'autre côté c'est
important dans certains cas avec
cavaliers 4 pourquoi pas ça fixe et on a
toujours à 4 à 5 après
n'est plus protégé mais je pense qu'on
peut se le permettre
j'aime pas trop l'idée de
d'avoir mon fou qui est pas protégé
c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup B3 en
fait
ça fera peut-être plus grand chose
mais à Tours
il y a une pression maintenant sur F7
par transparence
on peut vérifier qu'il y a quelque chose
mais ouais cavalier 3D
un petit peu les cases
et là c'est pas simple
sur ça peut-être échec et voilà mais bon
ça fait peur
comment ça va faire un peu peur
et sur ça
c'est pas mal parce que dans ma carte a
toujours éventuellement dans ma F6
est-ce que tu
j'ai dame G5 ou la finale d'un mètre 4
donc du coup surtout
il y a un truc pénible pas facile à
gérer
quatre mais du coup par contre
maintenant il y a les thèmes d'amocat
c'est vraiment une belle galère quand
même histoire c'est pas compliqué
[Musique]
j'ai une idée 4
tout à l'heure
et j'ai peut-être sur
Vérifier cette histoire
au pire j'ai quand même
[Musique]
attends on va peut-être aller voir
rapidement ce qui se passe chez
parce que
le roi qui se baladait
les débats il finit à 4 minutes 30
secondes
un petit peu la fin de 3 semaines
et au final
après tout ça
c'est de magouille un petit peu la
position
à chaque fois envoyer un quel que soit
le niveau en face ils essaient de créer
des turbulences mais bon là
il a vraiment inquiété enfin il était
pas loin de faire un peu plus quand même
donc là
intéressant en tout cas philosophe qui
se bat pour pas être éliminé et par
contre qui a perdu ses deux matchs qui
va à fonder 45 prochain match ça va être
dur pour pour se remettre complètement
on va revenir à la partie du coup qui
restait c'était saut contre offre allez
super intéressante en plus
et du coup
les revenus en défense ça pas duré très
longtemps en fait ça peut durer
[Musique]
s'il gagne comment ça pas gagner ce
champion
il a remis le fond un G2 c'est assez
marrant je trouve ah oui l'échange de
dame
alors par contre les dames c'est pas un
truc que j'aurais fait après maintenant
j'ai le droit le plus safe
mes pièces et puis je pousse le pion
quoi
ça m'étonne
ça m'étonne beaucoup ça reste
aussi
pas tout de suite parce que sinon je te
paierai à partir
et si je défends là peut-être je sens
que si je prends là
mon cavalier qui est un peu en PLS
si je prends la tête
non
il préfère regarder les dames ce qui est
aussi compréhensible je pense en fait
c'était il y a deux bonnes décisions
mais ça a coûté du temps
c'est son marrant petite séquence des
changes de dames on n'est pas sûr que
ah oui depuis un moment quand même
mesdames c'est quoi tout ceci
ça va être compliqué toi je pense il y a
pas de
donc c'est la partie
je vais MD4
fous c'est 6 a été joué en tout cas il
prend son temps depuis le début
so il tremble pas loin d'une minute
maintenant
d'une minute donc
Dame des deux je suis en H3 a priori
et mon fou il est hyper fort en fait il
tient tout il tient ça et tiens aussi le
mat enfin le matin en H1
donc je crois il y aura pas d'essai avec
ça et ça
et
donc fous moi ça m'a l'air gagnant assez
simple en fait hein maintenant qu'il a
il fallait un moment pousser le pion a
dans le bon condition c'est le seul
moyen si on passe pas après il a essayé
de voir s'il sent il pouvait passer ou
non qui est assez logique je pense oui
bien sûr
et faire attention au réseau de maths
avec le taureau
il a peur un petit peu se comprend avec
une minute pareil à tous trois faut pas
se faire pigeonner
ça répète un peu peut-être un cavalier
des cinq qui peut aussi arriver avec un
time C3 et chacun et sauf c’était quoi
surtout retro c'était chaud non
à la place
c'est chaud
oui oui c'est certain mais bon
si tu veux dans cette position
seul
une minute les mecs
on sentait que c'était ça depuis tout à
l'heure qu'il essaie de faire mais après
tu vois qu'il a joué deux donc il s'est
dit ouais ok il répète je répète tu vois
aussi en pratique il joue plus simple
donc là ils ont plus de temps chacun va
revenir en G5 maintenant
[Musique]
c'est vraiment top
qui est G5 par contre
mais maintenant il va gagner allez
attention que tu auras 7 Dame des 4
échecs
et puis non mais là si on prend la
diagonale et qu'on fait cavalier 4
derrière ça va être très très pénible
d'ailleurs il empêche
évidemment
on est en train de faire craquer le truc
[Musique]
on aurait échangé fou B5 attention
ça a l'air d'aller quand même
encore pas facile
et plus de temps tu vois qu'il lui reste
trois secondes à la pendule
il a joué KD2 ouais c'est chaud
reste 30 non il arrête à une seconde il
a joué sur la pendule
ceux qui souffle
c'est chaud c'est compliqué alors là sur
le sur le live il y a la caméra qui
s'actualisé
en tout cas ouais
n'importe quel moment en fait
là
il a pas le choix quand même avec les
Noirs il doit il doit continuer à
répéter
par contre c'est ceux qui quand même
envie c'est de gagner mais
[Musique]
bon elle peut pas mettre Laurent H3 je
pense que ça va faire parce que là c'est
quand même trop risqué mettre Laurent F3
c'est chaud
qui prend les risques après il y a
toujours cavaluer trois milieux au pire
des cas c'est ça c'est logique je pense
pour un joueur comme lui pour n'importe
qui d'ailleurs en plus vous savez c'est
l'engrenage aussi
ce qui perds pas le fondant ah non
pardon moi je vois à l'envers
ouais alors encore une fois je suis
désolé
mais
vous avez la vous avez la caméra qui
vous montre un petit peu les la position
les coûts ce qui se passe joli coup de
westf ou D3 ou des trois menaces
maintenant G6 soufflent
la partie ici il y a un échec en H1
c'est possible
une petite répète là dame j'ai un
parce que ça répète
la position qui s'est remise sur CSCOM
ça répète là peut-être pas le choix
qui va devoir faire nul peut-être
en tout cas franchement je me disais que
ça honnêtement j'avais hâte de voir
comment il allait gagner ça relativement
facilement mais en fait c'est dur pour
tout le monde surtout avec peu de temps
là ils ont pas de temps hyper tena en
tout cas le bec c'est franchement
monstrueux quand même parce que c'est
pas la première fois que je le vois
avoir des poubelles et tenir sa poubelle
jusqu'au bout et pas perdre c'est je
trouve que c'est ça mon frère qui a une
grande qualité exactement magnifique en
tout cas franchement 18 ans champion du
monde de parties rapides tiens saut en
cette partie alors qu'il était
complètement foutu franchement c'est
c'est beau
c'était très très simple peut-être la
plus belle ronde à laquelle on a assisté
pour cette fin de partie et le début de
partie de la partie Carlson Nakamura
je pense que la partie va reprendre
d'ici 5-10 minutes généralement voir 10
minutes de 10 bonnes minutes je pense
parce que tu sais il y a l'histoire du
ah oui il y aura pas le tirage au sort
je pense 10 minutes mais bon de toute
façon voilà on fait une petite pause et
après on revient sera la dernière partie
pour pour cette soirée et demain et
après-demain ça continue vous le savez
vous nous retrouverez avec stouffe pour
pour tout ça yes donc à tout de suite
pour le dédouement de la journée à tout
de suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà nous sommes de retour avec
Kevin et oui et on sait pas trop Janique
quand ça va quand ça va reprendre donc
ben on prend notre mal en patience voilà
tout simplement on a assisté à des
grosses grosses parties là précédemment
donc c'était super sympa et ben on
espère que pour la dernière ça va être
ça va être cool on a particulièrement
suivi avec souffle la partie entre
Carlson et Nakamura est dans le début
c'était fou un
ouais la partie a été complètement folle
on dirait on peut on peut la refaire un
petit peu avoir le début avoir commencé
donc là on pense que la partie va
reprendre dans 5 minutes à peu près en
tout cas c'est une mine en et donc ça
donne la partie de l'arron de 2 bah
tiens regarde celle qui arrive
donc Arsen qui a qui a battu un et demi
à un demi fait de CF et là qui a
commencé par une nulle contre Nakamura
avec les Noirs la partie assez marrant
enfin ça funky regardez juste pour voir
le début c'est assez drôle ma cage ou B3
et ici Kevin me dit ah il pourra pas
faire G6 et ben non il peut pas faire
d'ici s'il a fait G5 et ce qui est assez
drôle en fait c'est que sur le temps fou
ici et ma seule classe de sortie c'est
la case H3 et après D5 il va le fou
contre la case 3 et du coup tu menaces
ton G6 gagne la dame le projet et du
coup bah c'est la position elle est
également pour les noirs et c'est hyper
joli quoi c'est marrant quoi et donc du
coup dans la partie il y a eu G5 qui a
été joué par Carcel et donc il y a eu
l'échange des pièces B6 et là c'est
parti vraiment complètement en live dans
la position ou Naka a joué 4 pour
prendre le centre et sacrifier le pion
en fait pour jouer l'initiative après
un cas d'un point à 4 et le cavalier au
2 et là la séquence qui a vu ici elle
est juste magique des séquences déjà
même le cercle d'option stratégiquement
c'est fort
et là ici en fait les blancs menacent G3
qui va ouvrir complètement bah le roi
noir avec du jeu voilà avec du jeu et
après
avec les Blancs que ces pièces random et
du coup Carlson pour empêcher les trois
il a fait les trois lui-même et sur ce
Naka a joué affran G3 pas le choix et
bien il veut fixer avec M6 pour empêcher
ici à 4
c'est et ici
après qu'il y avait ce qui empêche G4 et
ben il y a eu quand même G4 de la part
de Carter ce qui est monstrueux pour en
fait jouer G3 donc c'est vraiment un jeu
d'initiative où chacun a son tour
sacrifie le matériel pour vraiment
s'activer etc donc je trouve que c'était
vraiment important
c'est vraiment des détails des nuances
très très fortes quoi et qui voit
vraiment ultra rapidement
et donc la partie a commencé d'ailleurs
et du coup car un scène qui ajoute P4
et
c'est marrant du coup B4 mais quand
d'ailleurs qui a été joué qui a été joué
dans d'autres parties donc on voit que
les joueurs sont préparés en fait
maintenant déjà il réfléchissent à ce
qu'ils vont jouer
il a jb4 et
du coup B4 qui a été quelque chose
marqué d'ailleurs c'était un feyde B5
il y a eu des 4 B5 pour montrer un peu
que c'est similaire les idées de sortir
de la dame et de contrôler le fou
c'est ça c'est logique et du coup après
BK
6 on va mettre du coup les seconds donc
c'est les entraîneurs si vous voulez des
séjours là et bien ils sont sur place et
ils réfléchissent ensemble à des
possibilités pendant que eux ils jouent
en fait et du coup tu as le temps de
vraiment pouvoir anticiper la partie
suivante peut-être idéal 5 ici pour les
Noirs parce qu'il faut trouver l'idée
pour sortir la dame
à 5 pour j'ai un peu comme ça il a
essayé de jouer à 5 B5 avec l'idée de
jouer à 4 etc merci pour le compliment
en tout cas je trouve que tu penses que
je vois un petit peu comme abdos
adorable c'est bien merci
[Rires]
j'ai deux par exemple cavalier F3 petit
rock et tu retournes bien dans des
schémas que qu'on connaît avec les
Blancs tu vois descente anglaise des
sortes de de début tu vois c'est rampant
donc on reste quand même dans des
schémas qu'on connaît et puis les Noirs
c'est un peu pareil hein tu m'as faire
quelque chose tu m'as cabane aussi c'est
un rock bon évidemment à 8 ok mais
à tout moment aussi pour pour travailler
sur G7 et sur carolier F6 est-ce que je
donne mon fou c'est une question
donc ok en tout cas ça a commencé comme
ça vraiment un petit peu à côté notre
partie voir où ils en sont juste pour
voir un cas débute on choisit et là on
voit absolument contre so donc il y a eu
encore un début assez classique tu vois
il a joué G3 cavaliers 3 rock pour jouer
en début tu vois classique quoi puis on
prend et au final
il joue sans théorie
donc voilà c'est un peu moins funky mais
ça reste quand même
[Musique]
très solide très bien
160 c'est vraiment un très très gros
avantage d'avoir les blancs
il va vraiment réussir à avoir une vraie
anglaise avec une tour en verre qui
serait bien placée pour se dégage
c'est ça reste indienne
donc du coup bah
il prépare ça un peu tôt c'est un peu
tôt
ok on va on va revenir sur quelle chaîne
c'est une sale tête
il faut qu'il trouve des arguments
si la position est un petit peu trop
trop plates ou trop pénible à jouer ça
fait pas ses affaires parce que il y
aura un petit plus blanc qui aime bien
maintenu
je comprends pas trop pourquoi
et pas pour A5 quel est le
quel est l'alternative blanche A5 je
sais pas trop comment il jouerait avec
les Blancs pas facile je trouve
mais ça a l'air ça a l'air hyper hyper
standard hyper malade parce que C6 ça a
l'air vraiment d'être locaux pour faire
à 5 structurellement parlant oui A4 mais
c'est ce que je voulais jouer parce que
je comprends pas si tu veux stuff
j'avais prévu A4 sur C6 enfin c'est ce
que je comprenais de la structure de
pion et
[Musique]
on essaie de vous montrer un petit peu
rarement comment les humains
pensent pas comme les machines
qu'à chaque fois il veut venir des
positions d'échecs classique c'est pas
vraiment qu'ils veulent revenir sur des
positions classiques mais ils sont
obligés de respecter qu'on nous a
toujours appris et ce qui est
intéressant sans centre développement
rock et après ils ont énormément de
schémas en tête donc c'est pas vraiment
qui vont aller sur du classique vraiment
volontairement
c'est ils connaissent tous les schémas
de toute façon donc ils seront obligés
de retrouver de retomber dans quelque
chose de connu voilà c'est c'est la base
donc en fait ils ont des repères déjà
sur certaines positions donc là la
position se prête quand même à position
de type anglaise tout ça donc ils
veulent rester dans leur schéma donc on
peut comprendre tu vois c'est quand même
un tournoi avec dedans en jeu si je suis
un peu la du monde de
[Musique]
mais après c'est vrai que non on préfère
les parties plus funky franchement la
partie de Maka cartienne de la partie de
l'avant elle m'a trouvé
B2 rock et je pense des trois C4 ça
risque d'être très sûrement les
très faciles à jouer quand même pour les
blancs j'ai l'impression
il y aura peut-être un fou en B2 du coup
c'est comme vraiment plus ce qu'il a
réussi à faire grâce à B4 A4 c'est par
rapport à plein de positions de type on
va dire anglaise ou position un peu
catalan tu vois avec et ben très souvent
la poussée on va dire
p4a4 attaque de minorité qui qui est
bien plus tard et là du coup après grâce
à avoir joué à 4 et B4 et ben il empêche
tous les coups comme à 5 tout ça et il a
trouvé comme une utilité Ardane qui va
jouer éventuellement ici alors que la
dame d'or cette pollution a vraiment du
mal à trouver l'équilibre
il y a un schéma qui existe comme on va
mettre déjà joué et que j'ai rejoué
moi-même d'ailleurs montré à des élèves
c'est dans le début rétique à ce même
schéma cavalier F3 cavalier F6 G3 G6 B4
pour prendre l'espace à la dame
c'est vraiment sympa
donc
du coup bah tu l'as ici et normalement
dans le début du Time une demande oui
ça peut même être une amélioration de la
pollution parce que la tour est en D1
aussi donc plutôt bien placée tu vois
sur la colonne des
et donc en tout cas 45 j'aime bien ce
qu'il fait dans cette dans ce petit
match j'ai vraiment l'impression quand
même que le préparation ça se passe
quand même plutôt bien pour lui
juste encore
donc ok cavaliers à 6 au début j'aimais
bien mais il y avait peut-être B5 qui
était vraiment très rigolo
les petites menaces en un coup je
regardais pas tout
juste
ton idée
ton idée ça pouvait pas être ça
bon
c'est même pas voulu non
c'est 3 qui arrive
tu vas perdre en fait tu vas perdre ton
cheval en fait
il est pas d'accord avec moi d'ailleurs
par l'élimination
quand même mais bon faut à 3 et 4 plus
de cavalier B4
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai envie de faire oui parce que
Descartes ce serait dommage peut-être
dans la 2e
peut-être que les pièces de Nakamura
sont un peu bizarre
je pense que Rock est quand même doit
être vu ou deux trois enfin ça fait pas
trop peur
c'était vraiment pas mal je pense
ok mais bon petit rock des trois ou des
trois petits rocks
quand même à terme
alors c'est bien